AFTERNOON IN RESPONSE TO THE
CODE NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC SENATORS AND
SENATE STAFF WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS WE
ARE HOLDING OUR INFORMATIONAL
HEARING HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WITH THE USE OF THE VIDEO
MEETING SERVICE BUT SOME OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WILL BE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY TODAY.
WITH THE USE OF A VIDEO MEETING
SERVICE OUR PANELISTS WITH OUR
PANELISTS FROM STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT THE NURSING HOME
INDUSTRY AND NURSING HOME
REFORM ADVOCATES WILL BE
PARTICIPATING AS WELL THROUGH
THE VIDEO SERVICE. IN ADDITION
TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS OF
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO HEARING ROOM TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE ORVIS.
FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY ON TODAY'S AGENDA. FOR
ANYONE WHO WILL BE ATTENDING
REMOTELY TODAY PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONES OUR COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK AND I ASK
THAT. EVERY TIME YOU HAVE A
COMMENT OR QUESTION USE. THE
RESERVE HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM JUST AS A REMINDER.
EACH TIME YOUR KNOWLEDGE TO
SPEAK A POP UP WINDOW WILL
APPEAR ASKING IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO ON MUTE PLEASE SELECT IN ME
BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING. FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PRO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT I WILL
PROVIDE THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER. AND ACCESS CODE AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME AND IT IS
ON THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE NOW.
WHEN WE MOVED TO PUBLIC
COMMENT. THE MODERATOR WILL
IDENTIFY YOU INDIVIDUALLY OPEN
YOUR LINE AND AT THAT TIME YOU
MAY ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE IN THIS. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUALS WERE DISRUPTIVE MAY
BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
HEARING MEETING SERVICE. OR
HAVE THEIR COMMUTE CONNECTIONS
MUTED. WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS
BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINE THE
HEARING PROCESS AND CONDUCTOR
HEARINGS AND IT'S CLOSE TO THE
MATTER AS IS CUSTOMARY THERE
MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS WERE ADJUSTING. TO
THE USED OR NEW ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES TO PLEASE BE
RESPECT I'M PATIENT. THE ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING. FOR BE.
A US TODAY THIS HERE IS TO THE-
HOW THE CODE NINETEEN PENDANT.
IS IMPACTING THOSE WHO LIVE IN
OR WORK IN CALIFORNIA SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES. IN RECENT
YEARS AND ON MULTIPLE OCCASIONS
THE LEGISLATURE HAS PASSED THE
STATE. AUDITOR TO TAKE A DEEP
LOOK AT MANY OF CALIFORNIA'S
NURSING HOMES. AND THE WORK OF
STATE LEGIS STATE REGULATORS
RESPONSIBLE FOR LICENSING AND
MONITORING THEIR OPERATION. IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE STATE
AUDITOR CONCLUDED THAT FROM
200-062-2015 THE NUMBER OF
SUBSTANDARD CARE DEFICIENCY
THAT NURSING FACILITIES
RECEIVED INCREASED BY 31% THE
STATE AUDITOR ALSO CONCERN THAT
STATE PANEL FILTER PAY BY. THE
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES WHEN
CITATIONS WERE ISSUED FOR
DEFICIENCIES MAY NOT CREATE AN
ADEQUATE DETERRENT FOR NURSING
FACILITIES PROVIDING
SUBSTANDARD QUALITY OF CARE.
THAT WE ENTERED THE CODE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC WITH A
NURSING HOME SYSTEM IN NEED OF
MANY IMPROVEMENTS IN A NUMBER
OF AREAS. ONE OF THE FIRST
KNOWN OUTBREAKS OF KOBE
NINETEEN COUNTRY OCCURRED.
THING IN A NURSING HOME IN THE
STATE OF WHAT AND FIVE EVEN
WITH THE EARLY NOW THAT COULD
NINETEEN COULD QUICKLY AMONG A
FORMER NURSING HOME POPULATION
CALIFORNIA'S EXPERIENCES
SIMILAR TO STATES THROUGHOUT
THE NATION AND THAT MANY OF OUR
NURSING HOMES HAVE NOW BEEN HIT
WITH KOBE NINETEEN WITH
DEVASTATING CONSEQUENCES FOR
OUR RESIDENTS HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONALS AND THEIR
FAMILIES MORE THAN 40% OF THE
CODE NINETEEN DEATHS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE ASSOCIATED WITH
NURSING FACILITIES AND IT'S
CLEAR THAT WE NEED TO CONTINUE
MAKING CHANGES I LOOK FORWARD
TO HEARING THE WITNESSES AND MY
COLLEAGUES. HE TELLS ON WHAT
HAS THE CURRENT IT STATE ROAD
TO SING HOMES AND WHAT ACT THE
STATE AND LOCAL HEALTH THE HAVE
BEEN TAKING TO ADDRESS THIS.
FROM THE NURSING INDUSTRY
ITSELF AS WELL I ALSO WANT TO
WELCOME MY CULTURE SENATOR
BATES AND WE DO HAVE SOME
WELCOME AS WELL FROM SENATOR
PAN SENATOR PAN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND I WANT TO THANK
YOU MUCH FOR BEING THIS HE- ON.
CALVET AND SKILL NURSING.
CERTAINLY AS WE'RE SAYING I AND
RIDE AND OF AT NIGHT AND FOR
PROP PERHAPS PROBABLY. TRACED
BACK TO MORRELL GATHERING AND
LIST SOME OF THE AT HOME ORDER
FROM THERE WE SHOULD MAKE THAT
APPROXIMATELY. AN INCH OR WILL
THROUGH THE OF THE OF THE THAT
HAVE AND CAL. THAT A AMONGST
LIVED NURSING. NOW I WHAT I
WANTED POINT OUT IS ALSO A IS
THAT AS GOVERNOR HAS OUT GUIDE.
FOR REAL CAL. HE IS STRONGLY
MAY NOTE THAT. THESE ACTUAL
THIS ARE TO BE LOW. THAT THANK
YOU LO QUE YA LOCAL TO
TERMINATE. WHICH MEANS WERE
VERY REAL ON A PUBLIC HEALTH
OFF IP FOR HEARING GONNA
HEARING FROM MY TIME PUBLIC
HEALTH OFICER. BUT I THINK
IT'S AN TO. AND I APPRECIATE
AGAIN UNTIL THAT. SEVEN COUNTY
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER HAVE
RISEN SINCE MISTER MID APRIL.
SO ALL RIGHT SO WE HAVE A WE DO
HAVE A CRISIS FOR COUNTY PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICER NOW SOME OF THEM
HAVE BEEN PRE PLANNED BEFORE
KOBE SOME OF THEM MAYBE BE OF
THE WORK BY. THE REASON FEEL
COMPELLED TO UP AND MENTION
THAT IS BECAUSE- ON MONDAY
NIGHT THE PUBLIC HEALTH FRONT
RESIGN. AND IT PROBABLY WASN'T
TO OVERWORK WASN'T SIR PLAN AT
LEAST A NOT YOU KNOW WAY IF THE
FOR CO. IS UNDER CIRCUMSTANCES
FOR THIS PUBLIC HEALTH OFF.
WHAT IS PERSONALLY ATTACKED
WITH DEATH THREATS PER ADDRESS
WAS. AND NOW AT A HEARING THE
INTO TO PEOPLE. TO FURTHER
ATTACKS HER AND TO SHOW BETTER
HOME. AND I THINK THIS IS
TOTALLY UNACCEPTABLE. DOCTOR
CLICK WHETHER YOU AGREE OR
DISAGREE WITH HER AS A PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICER IS A DEDICATED
PUBLIC SERVANT WHO IS DOING HER
BEST TO TRY TO PROTECT ORANGE
COUNTY FROM A PUBLIC HEALTH
THREAT JUST LIKE EVERY OTHER
COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICERS
TRYING TO FEND COUNTY FROM
PUBLIC HEALTH THREAT. AND IF WE
IS A STATE ARE YOU TO THAT
LOCALS DETERMINERS WHICH IS A-
THEN WE NEED TO PROTECT OUR
COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICERS
THEY NEED TO HAVE THE SUPPORT
FROM THE STATE. AND IT'S TO SAY
THE L. PERHAPS THE PURSE
PROTECT. THIS IS CERTAINLY NOT
BE SOME TO ATTACKS. TWO DIOXANE
INCITING PEOPLE TO GO ATTACK
THEIR THEMSELVES PERSONALLY IN
THEIR FAMILIES TO BALLING
INTIMIDATION AND SO AS WE ARE
HERE TODAY TO HEAR THIS VERY
IMPORTANT TOPIC ABOUT. NURSING
HOMES AND TO COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. WE I ALSO HOPE THAT
ALL OF US WELL PUBLICLY. THE
END. AND DEFEND OUR COUNTY
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICERS BUT THEY
HAVE TO MAKE VERY DIFFICULT
DECISIONS TO HELP PROTECT OUR
PUBLIC AND OUR HOUSE THANK YOU
SO MUCH MAN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
PANIC. THAT BEFORE WE BE
TODAY'S HEARING- A WEEK PLEASE
HAVE THE SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE. SENATOR GONZALEZ.
PRESENT GONZALEZ PRESENT
SENATOR BATES. BATES PRESENT
SENATOR BOARD JUST. SENATOR
CABALLERO. SENATOR DODD.
SENATOR JACKSON JACKSON PRESENT
SENATOR JONES HERE CENTER JONES
PRESIDENT PRESENT SENATOR
MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE PRESENT
SENATOR PAN PAN PRESENT SENATOR
UMBERG. RESIDENTS NUMBER
PRESENT. SENATOR WIENER. THANK
YOU AND BEFORE WE CAN WITH OUR
SPEAKING WITH OUR SPEAKERS I
WOULD LIKE TO INVITE- THE
PUBLIC WOULD LIKE TO
PARTICIPATE TO CALL IN NOW
PLEASE DIAL THIS TOLL FREE
NUMBER. 1-844-291-6364 WHEN
PROMPTED PLEASE USE THIS ACCESS
CODE SIX THREE TWO. SIX EIGHT
THREE ZERO NOW FOR MY
COLLEAGUES AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- WE HAVE FIVE PANELISTS
EACH WILL BE GIVEN ABOUT FIVE
MINUTES EACH ARE WE WILL RUN
THROUGH EACH PANELIST BACK TO
BACK AND THEN WE WILL OPEN IT
UP FOR QUESTIONS FROM- THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. NOW LET
THAT'S YOUR FIRST AND WE WOULD
LIKE TO THANK HEIDI SIGN
OCCURRED DEPUTY DIRECTOR CENTER
FOR THE CENTER FOR HEALTH CARE
QUALITY AT THE CENTER OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH C. PH THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE AND WELCOME
SPINNAKER. GREAT THANK YOU SO
MUCH MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
FOR ALLOWING ME THE TIME TODAY
TO SHARE WITH YOU AND HAVE A
DISCOURSE. ALONG WITH SOME OF
OUR IMPORTANT STAKEHOLDERS IN
OUR LOCAL COMPOUND COUNTY
HEALTH OFFICERS AS WELL. I
WANTED TO FIRST DAY THAT YOU
KNOW THIS THE KINDA. DEFINITELY
THE MID INEQUITIES THAT ARE HOW
CARE SO. AS WELL AS THE- THAT
EXIST WITHIN OUR NATIONAL
HEALTH QUALITY AND SAFETY
OVERSIGHT SYSTEM. THIS IS NOT
JUST A CALIFORNIA ISSUE THIS IS
A NATIONAL ISSUE. ALL FIFTY
STATES IN THE UNITED STATES USE
THE CMS QUALITY AND SAFETY
OVERSIGHT MODEL. WHICH IS A
ONCE A YEAR AND WILL VISIT TO A
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY. IN
ADDITION TO WHATEVER-
INVESTIGATIONS OR FACILITY
INCIDENTS THAT MIGHT BE
RECORDED. IT'S A VERY REACTIVE
PROCESS. YOU GO IN ON SCHEDULE
TIMES AND ANNOUNCED AND YOU GO
IN AFTER SOMETHING HAS ALREADY
HAPPENED. AND WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO IS YOU PA IS CRAIG SISTER
GOING OUT OF THIS PENDANT IT
TAKES SOME OF THE PAIN TRAUMA
THAT WE WITNESSED. THROUGHOUT
THIS PANDEMIC TO BE ABLE TO
CREATE SYSTEMS THAT WILL LONG
AT LAST AFTER POST PANDEMIC
THAT WILL IMPROVE OUR QUALITY
AND SAFETY OVERSIGHT NOT JUST
DURING. BUT FOR YEARS TO COME.
SOME OF THOSE EFFORTS ALL WALK
YOU THROUGH. BUT I DO WANT TO
ECHO THAT. BEFORE WASHINGTON
HAD THEIR SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY OUTBREAK WE WERE
ALREADY WATCHING ITALY WE WERE
ALREADY WATCHING WHAT WAS
HAPPENING IN OTHER COUNTRIES.
AROUND THE WORLD PARTICULARLY
TO THEIR SKILLED NURSING. YOU
THAT THIS WOULD BE AN ISSUE
WHICH IS WHY WE ACTIVATED THE
MEDICAL HEALTH COORDINATION
CENTER ON JANUARY TWENTY
FOURTH. WE'VE ALL BEEN WORKING
SEVEN DAYS A WEEK SINCE THAT
DAY. ON THE TWENTY EIGHTH WE
STARTED HAVING ALL FACILITY
CALLS AND PROVIDING GUIDANCE
DOCUMENTS NOT JUST TAKE
HOSPITALS BUT PARTICULARLY TO
OUR SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES.
AND I'VE HAD SEVERAL ADDITIONAL
WEEKLY CALLS THAT FOCUS ON
CHEST INFECTION PREVENTION. FOR
OUR NURSING HOMES. WE LOOKED AT
OTHER STATES WE LOOKED
INTERNALLY AND WE FOUND THAT
ALL OF US HAD NOT ONLY A
NATIONAL SHORTAGE OF PP BUT
THERE WAS A GLOBAL SHORTAGE YOU
PP EARLIER AND I'M. SO BEST HAD
ISSUE WITH TRYING TO FIGURE
WAYS TO HAVE. BETTER PP SYSTEM.
ALL OF US STAFF SHORTAGE ACROSS
ALL OF STATE. AND ALL OF THE
WERE TRY TO WHICH INFO PER. AS
WE NOTE THAT THIS IS AN IN.
THAT PRETTY. JUST HAVE THE- OR
STABLE WORK FORCE. TO BE ABLE
TO SURE THAT THEY ARE
COMFORTABLE WITH DONNIE AND
DOFFING. COMFORTABLE WITH
SPEAKING SURE THAT THEY'RE NOT.
CONTAMINATING ON AND SO WANTED
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE- PROVIDED
IN THE HOUSE EDUCATION. SO
THERE WE TRIPLED THE A- OF OUR
HEALTH OF WHY. STRIKE TEAMS. ON
WITHIN ONE MONTH. BOB WE ALL
THEN READER ALL ONE OF OUR-
HEALTH THIS EVALUATE NURSES
FROM THERE RIGHT. SURVEY
SCHEDULE INTO GOING INTO
ACTIVELY INTO THESE FACILITIES
TO PROVIDE. PREVENTION TRAINING
WE DID WEBINARS AS WELL AS ON
SITE IN PERSON TRAINING. ON HOW
TO DO ALL OF THESE INFECTIONS.
CALL. BUT IT WASN'T ENOUGH I WE
RECKON. THAT THE PIN WHEN IN
THE CASES ARISE AND DOES.
PRICING NO HOW MUCH EDUCATE WE
GAVE NO MATTER HOW MUCH P. D.
EITHER WE TRY TO CREATE. FOR
WE'RE STAFFING. WE CREATED THE
HEALTH HEALTH COOL WE HAD
COUNTRY STAY THAT WE HAD A BILL.
WE TRIED TO DO. IT BUT IT WAS
STILL WASN'T BECAUSE WE STILL A
VERY REACTIVE. SO IN APRIL WE
DECIDE TO CREATE A- URGENT
NEEDS TO FOR. WE WERE THAT
EVERY SKILLED TO. MUST FOR
THEIR- BY NOON. AND AS THE
RIVER THERE FROM. AND OUR
SURVEYOR SEVEN DAYS A WEEK FOR
WATCHED A DASH. WHERE WITH
THEIR LIFE. THE STILL WHEN THE
AND THEIR FROM. IT'LL EITHER UP
IS A GREEN LIGHT AS OR AS A- IN
A BILL IN. YOU SEE WHAT IT
MEANS THEY HAVE. BUT THAT
WASN'T ENOUGH SO THEY WE
DECIDED TO CREATE SOME PROJECT
AMANDA. SO THEN WE FIVE ON A
ALL THE CA DATA FROM. I WELL AS
TAKING THE IT IN FOR WE'RE
GETTING A DALY AND THEN TRYING
TO PREDICT WHO WOULD BE ARE
HIGH RISK. AND THEN CALL THEM
AND BE CON THEM AND BY FOR ON
SITE VISIT. I'M SINCE THE- WE
HAVE NOW WE'RE SO A MASK. FOR
THE FIRST MONTHS THE SNAP. FROM
MARCH TO JUNE. AND WE FOR THAT
HELD EVE THOUGH WE TWELVE AND
FOUR. WHICH IS AND THE AMOUNT
WITH. AND VETS. AND ANY OTHER
STATE. WE ARE TWENTY THIRD.
WHEN IT COMES TO. THE DEATH
RATE FOR WHAT THE- AND WE
BELIEVE THAT BECAUSE I AVERAGE
JUST READ IS SO LOW. IT TO HELP
PEOPLE WE HAVE TO PROTECT SERVE
SO MANY REMOTE. GEOGRAPHIC DOG.
WE THINK IT IS BECAUSE OF THIS
OF GO. ON SITE AND HAVING
PHYSICAL. WE'VE ALSO BEEN ON
SITE AND HAD MORE PHYSICAL.
THAT ANY OTHER STATE IN FACT.
CALLED ME I. THEY WERE TO KNOW
WHY WE'RE DOING DIFFERENTLY
THAN OTHERS AND HOW THEY CAN.
IT IN OTHER AS A MODEL. BUT
AGAIN WE RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS
NOT ENOUGH THIS IS GOING TO
HAVE TO BE A LONG TERM. HOW DO
WE- OVER HEALTH CARE QUALITY.
FOR LONG TERM. SO WE HAVE SIX
CREEK STREET. ALSO WITH YOU
THAT ALL HE THEM HE MY TIME.
FIRST IS A TESTING STRATEGY
WHICH IS YOU KNOW TO CALL.
REQUIRES ALL. TESTING BY
THIRTY. AS WELL AS- TO OF
HEALTH CARE. IN RETEST WEEK FOR
ANY FIRST THAT HAS A PASTA.
WILL ENSURE PREVENTION I DO YOU
WORK FOR SIX. PLAN AS FAR AS
MAKING SURE THAT OF LOCAL
HEALTH JURISTIC. ARE SUPPORT
WITH MORE I CAN RESOURCE. AS
WELL AS REQUIRED THAT ALL SNIFF
HOW EASE FULL TIME I SPOKE I HE-
AS WELL HAVING A- OUR I KEEP.
THE STATE WE CAN HELP BOLSTER
TRAIN. THAT ALSO LEAD TO THE
THIRD ONE WHICH IS SURE THE I
KEEP. OR ITS ACTION BY AT. IS
DONE NOT JUST THREE REMOTELY
ALSO IN HER DIRECT TO THOSE
NEED TO IT MOST FOURTH WE WANT
TO BE ABLE TO REFORM. HOW WE DO
OUR OF STATE YOU EVER SAW. SO
IN A DAY TO THE C. M. MODEL
GOING IN A YEAR. WE WANT TO
CREATE A ROBUST STATE. IN WHICH
I WOULD THAT EACH SIR WOULD
RESPONSE HAVE MORE. AND HAVE
WEEKLY. VISITS WITH THE SKILLED
THE TO. QUALITY AND STATE
OVERSIGHT. WE ALSO WANT TO DO
THIS AND MOBILE APP. AND A
CLOUD BASSIST WHERE EIGHT THE
STILL CAN MIST AND A OF ABOUT
THIRTY MORE SO. BUT YOU. AND
OUR STAFF BE ABLE TO DEAL EVERY
ELECT. READ THAN MANUALLY
ALASKA NOT LEAST COURSE THE
AGAIN. SO THANK YOU AGAIN YOUR
TIME AND HAVE TO SERVE FOR
CA. I DO HAVE A STOP
ADOLESCENCE BUT I WILL BE UNTIL
THAT. THANK YOU A WE REALLY A-
THAT TED. IN NEXT WE WILL HEAR
FOR DOCTOR JOHN. GUNS IN HIGH
HOW CHIEF MEDICAL FOR ELLIE KAY
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH WELCOME
DOCTOR AND WE YOU BEING HERE IS
WELL. MORNING I THANK YOU
CHAIRED AND MEMBERS THE SPECIAL
COMMITTEE THE OP. TO LOS
ANGELES SO. AND WORK WITH SKILL
NURSING. DURING OPEN. I'M
JEFFREY GUNS HOUSE OR MEDICAL
OFFICER FOR ELLIE KAY
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH. LA
COUNTY IS COME TO THE- AND POP
PRACTICES STEPS. REBEKAH HEALTH
WELL BEING OF THE POP. THEY
UNDER THE LEADERSHIP OF OUR
WORD AND TO PROVIDE MARK RIDLEY.
AND SHARE CATHERINE PARKER KAY
REACHED AT THE A MODE. TO
APPOINT AN ANSWER CHEN.
PROVIDER ON THE OVERSIGHT AND
OP TO **** IN OUR- WILL BE
WORKING WITH INSPECTORS ONCE.
TO ENSURE THE STATE. AND WELL
BEING OF THOSE THESE MOST FOR
READ. OF THIS MORNING OUT BRIEF
PROVIDE YOU BACK OF OR ROLL WAS.
ARE EFFORTS TO STRIP AND CAN
AND- I'M A THE CHALLENGE WE'VE-
AND CAN WITH A LOT FOR MOVING
FORWARD TO ENSURE FOR THIS. IN
POPULAR. SEVERAL THINGS ARE NO
WE'RE ABOUT STATE YOU FIRST
OVER A- OF THE STATE'S HELL
CARE. ARE LOW IN OUR TOWN.
SECOND WERE THE ONLY COUNTY THE
STATE AND NAY AT PERFORMS.
ANSWERED ON OF STATE SINCE THE
NINETEEN SO ALL COUNTY HAS FOR.
THE FUNDED. YOUR CON WITH THE
OF HEALTH THE STATE TO PERFORM
THIS WORK. JULY OF LAST YEAR
WOULD BE A NEW THREE YEAR.
WHICH FULL SOME. OF THE WORK
LOW GENERATE BY HELL CARE FOR.
WITHIN THE COUNTY YOU ARE ALL.
SINCE DIVISION. AND THIRD ARE
TO. IS UNIQUE IN A HEALTH AL
REACH WHICH WRECK WORK WITH
HEALTHCARE. REDRESS ISSUES OF
ACTION AND PREVENTION SO WE ARE
UNIQUELY. TO RISK UNDER
CHALLENGES BETTER. KOBE NINE
EARLIER YEAR. AMONG THE THREE
HUNDRED FOR. FREE STAY BUILDING
CAMPUS. IN INSTITUTIONS
INCLUDING SNAPS AMONG THE
COUNTY'S TWO THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO DEATHS ONE
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
FOUR OR 51% EVER HEARD AMONG
RESIDENTS IN SNAPS. WE
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
ASYMPTOMATIC INFECTION IN APRIL
AND RECOMMENDED UNIVERSAL
MASKING AT THAT TIME. THE SAME
TIME WE ADOPTED A MASS TESTING
STRATEGY A TEST KITS AVAILABLE
ALL THIS. PLAYER OWN STRIKING
TO SPECIMENS. RESIDENTS AND
STAFF BASED ON THOSE RESULTS WE
ASSIST FACILITIES AND CO
BOARDING RESIDENTS BASED ON
WHETHER THEY'VE BEEN INFECTED
OR THEY'VE BEEN EXPOSED AS A
MEANS TO LIMIT FURTHER SPREAD.
TODAY TO DATE MORE THAN TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY THE THREE
HUNDRED FIFTEEN STEPS ARE
COMPLETED BASELINE FOR OUTBREAK
RELATED TESTING AND THE
REMAINDER WILL BE DONE WITHIN
THE NEXT WEEK. WE WORK WITH OUR
COUNTY CMS AGENCY TO MONITOR PP
SUPPLY AND OF HEALTH AND
DISTRIBUTING PP AS SOON AS IT
HAS BEEN AVAILABLE. WE HELP
**** THE TRESPASSING SHORTAGE
SHORTAGES INCLUDING REQUESTING
ASSISTANCE FROM THE STATE
FEDERAL LEVELS NATIONAL GUARD
NBA TEAMS HAVE BEEN DEPLOYED
MORE THAN A DOZEN STOPS.
WORKING WITH THE CDC WE POST
MULTIPLE TRAINING SESSIONS
BUILD CAPACITY MANAGING PREVENT
OUTBREAKS AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
WE'VE OBSERVED A RECENT MARKED
DECREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
DEATHS OCCURRING AMONG
RESIDENTS THESE FACILITIES. IT
REALLY SUPPORT THE NEEDS OF
**** HAS MET MANY CHALLENGES
SHORTAGE IS A PT HAVE BEEN
MAJOR ISSUE BOTH FOR **** STAFF
AS WELL AS FOR OWN STAFF. WE'VE
DEPLOYED. THIS WOULD. YES HE
WAS FAIRLY MINUTE UNTIL THE CAL
AND LA CITY TO OUR OWN SUPPLY
FOR TO. REAL LOCAL LAB. SOME
SNIFFED STAFF TO TEST BUT M<c.cyan></c>
DON'T. WE RESPOND BY MAKE OUR
OWN STAFF OR- STAFF AVAIL TO
MEET NEED. THIS IS BEEN VERY
REESE CENTER. TESTING HAS FACED
MALL IS CHALLENGES AS I'M SURE
YOU WILL HEAR ABOUT. ANOTHER
ISSUE IS FEAR AMONG BOTH SNIFF
AND DEPARTMENT STAFF AND THIS
IS BEEN A SIGNIFICANT ISSUE. WE
WORK CLOSELY WITH OUR LABOR
PARTNERS IN THE COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL HEALTH
DRESS WORKER CONCERNS TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT. TRANSFERS OF
PATIENTS BETWEEN HOSPITALS AND
SNATCHES BEEN A MAJOR CHALLENGE
WE'VE WORKED HARD BOTH WITH
HOSPITALS AND FACILITY. TO
DEVELOP APPROACHES TO PREVENT
UNNECESSARY TRANSFERS AND ALLOW
EARLY REPATRIATIONS GO
DEVELOPING OPEN UNIX. RECEIVE
OPEN INFECTED ASIANS A FEW
THOUGHTS FOR MOVING FORWARD. I
WOULD LIKE TO SAY THE LA COUNTY
REALLY. IT'S THE ONGOING OR- BE
AND CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE TECH
RESIDENTS OF **** AND OTHER
POPULATIONS PARTICULARLY PAUL
PAUL. OUT COMES IN NINETEEN ANY
EFFORT YOU CAN PROVIDE SOME.
FOLLOWING WOULD BE GREATLY.
FIRST IN HEY THE CUP OF LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT JUST OR
INFECTION CAN. ISSUES AND WIDE
RANGE OF HEALTH CARE FACILITIES
WITHIN THEIR JURISDICTION
INCLUDING SNAPS SECOND SUPPORT
INFORMATION SYSTEMS TO BETTER
TRACK HEALTH OUTCOMES AND
RELATED HEALTH SERVICES SUCH AS
TESTING. RELATION TO
COMMUNICABLE DISEASES AND SNAPS
THIRD SUPPORT OPPORTUNITIES FOR
**** TO RECEIVE EMERGENCY
FUNDING AND SERVICES TO RESPOND
OUTBREAKS INCLUDING INCREASED
CASTINGA BOTH RESIDENTS AND
STAFF. AND FOURTH GRADE SYSTEMS
AND SERVICES THAT ENHANCE THE
PROTECTION OF HEALTHCARE
WORKERS THIS CAN TRAIN NEW
SERVICES CRITICAL RESPONDTO
EMERGING INFECTIONS WITHIN OUR
FACILITIES. I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR KIND ATTENTION AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO ANSWERING ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR GUNS AND HOUSE
ARE WE APPRECIATE THAT AS WELL
AND NEXT WE WILL MOVE ON TO
OUR- THIRD PRESENTER. WHO IS
DOCTOR SERRA CODY SENATE CLEARS
COUNTY SANTA CLARA COUNTIES
HEALTH OFFICER AFTER. IS
ACTUALLY ONLY AVAILABLE INTO
TEN AM THIS MORNING SO MAKE
SURE SHE- GETS ON ACCESS AND Q.
WILL. THANK YOU AB MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ARE
SERRA. AND AGAIN I'M HELP ON
FOR THE COUNTY OF SANTA I WILL
JUST GIVE YOU A- BRIEF OVERVIEW
OF OUR COUNTY OF OUR APPROACH.
TO PREVENTING- ILLNESS AND
DEATH AMONG ARSONIST RESIDENTS-
AND THEN SHARE WITH YOU A
LITTLE BIT OF DATA FRO OUR
COUNTY. SO WOULD YOU KNOW- WE
ARE A COUNTY OF ABOUT ONE POINT
NINE MILLION- IN THE BAY AREA
THE LARGEST JURISDICTION IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA- AND THE
HEART OF SILICON VALLEY- WE-
EARLY ON AGAIN WATCHING THE
EXPERIENCE IN THE STATE OF
WASHINGTON WAS VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT OUR- SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES AND OTHER LONG TERM
CARE FACILITY- AS- AS BEING
REALLY ESSENTIALLY LIKE DRY
TENDER- IT AS FAR AS- HOPE IT
GOES AND WE WERE QUITE- QUITE
CONCERNED ABOUT OUR RESIDENTS
THERE. I THINK OUR OVERALL
APPROACH IS REALLY THREE FOLD-
ONE TO PREVENT- INTRODUCTION
OF- OF KOBE INTO LONG TERM CARE
FACILITIES AND INTO A VERY
VULNERABLE POPULATION. I TO
EARLY DETECTION- SO THAT WE CAN
PICK UP A PROBLEM EARLY AND
THREE. OF COURSE IS
CONTAINMENT- SO THAT WE CAN GET
AN OUTBREAK UNDER CONTROL AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE AFTER WE
DETECT IT- OUR WORK ACTUALLY
STARTED- IN IN EARLY MARCH WE
WERE FORTUNATE IN THAT WE HAD-
COLLEAGUES FROM THE CENTERS FOR
DISEASE CONTROL AND PREVENTION.
DEPLOYED TO THE COUNTY THIS WAS
BECAUSE WE WERE ONE OF THE
FIRST COUNTIES IN THE STATE- TO
HAVE IDENTIFIED CODED CASES. SO
WE HAD QUITE A BIT OF HELP
EARLY ON- SO BACK IN EARLY
MARCH WE HAD CONTACT. A HUNDRED
AND THREE SKILLED NURSING. AND
OTHER LONG TERM CARE FACILITY
TO REVIEW EACH FACILITIES AND
FACTION PREVENTION POLICY AND
TO REINFORCE. REINFORCE THAT
GUIDANCE- MOST OF THE WORK HAS
BEEN- WE'VE REALLY HAD TO
CREATE AN ENTIRE INFRASTRUCTURE
IN OUR EMERGENCY OPERATIONS
CENTER. IN ORDER TO. TO PREVENT
DETECT AND CONTAIN OUTBREAKS OF
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY
NORMALLY DESPITE THE SIZE OF
OUR COUNTY WE HAVE ONE PERSON.
WHO HELPS PREVENT AND CONTROL
OUTBREAKS IN INSTABILITY WE NOW
HAVE A WHOLE UNIT. SPECIAL
INVETIGATIONS UNIT WITHIN OUR
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS CENTER I
THINK WE DEVOTED TO PREVENTING
AND CONTROLLING- COBIT. IN LONG
TERM CARE FACILITIES. SO JUST
TO GIVE A VERY BRIEF OVERVIEW
OF WHAT THAT UNIT- HAS HAS DONE
I THINK THAT THE NUMBERS-
REALLY TELL TELL A STORY EIGHT.
WE HAD INCREASING ILLNESS AND
DEATH IN OUR SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES THAT PEAK IN MID
APRIL AND AS OF NOW WE HAVE NO
CURRENT OUTBREAKS WE HAVE VERY
VERY FEW CASES- ALL TOLD AMONG
OUR OUR LONG TERM CARE
FACILITY. AND STAFF AND
RESIDENTS ANYONE ASSIST YOU
BUT- DO YOU REPRESENT ABOUT
SIXTEEN OF OUR CASES HOWEVER.
GILDERSLEEVE FACILITY RESIDENTS
REPRESENTS- ALMOST 48% OF THE
DEATHS IN OUR COUNTY- WHICH IS
OF COURSE I'M SIMILAR TO THE
TOP. THAT IS CHEATING. THE
STATE HARPER BEN TO BE EX HANDS
ON SO IF ARE WE HAVE BEEN STAR
AT AND THEN JUST IT TO ARE FOR
HUGE IS IN OUR IS AS ELSEWHERE
WE DISTRIBUTED MASS AMOUNTS TO
TORQUE TO FILL. ARE FISCALLY AS
A DOCTOR GUNS AND HOUSE ARE
MEANT FOR LA ARE ALSO REALLY
STRUGGLING WITH TESTING- AND SO
WE HAVE RESOURCE TESTING WHERE
IT'S NEEDED WHETHER IT STANDING
UP A- A TESTING SITE OR HAVING
OUR STAFF THE WIND. WE ALL CAN
ACCOUNTED A LOT OF ISSUE. IN WE
HAD TO. WITH LARGE OUTBREAKS
THAT HAS SHORTAGES DUE TO FEAR
DUE TO ILLNESS AND WE ARE. SO
IN OUR COUNTY NURSE AND
CONTRACTORS INTERNSHIPS TO
ENSURE THAT THERE WERE CAUGHT
ME IS CARE FOR RESIDENTS DURING
DURING THAT REAL. COLD. SO IN
SHORT I WOULD SAY THAT THIS IS
BEEN INCREDIBLY REACH CENTER
AND THE JUST TO ECHO WHAT
OTHERS HAVE HIGHLIGHTED OUR
PRIMARY CHALLENGES HEAD BAND-
PP SHORTAGES- STAFFING ISSUES
PARTICULARLY- VERY HIGH STAFF
TURNOVER SO ONCE SOMEONE IS
TRAINED IN INFECTION CONTROL
THE NEXT TIME WE ENTER THE
FACILITY WE DISCOVERED THAT
THERE ARE NEW STAFF THERE
BECAUSE THE VERY HIGH VERY HIGH
TURNOVER AND PPP AT PP ISSUES
ONE FINAL TO THE HIGH BEFORE I.
AFTER PART OF THAT WE NOTED
THAT WHEN WE HAVE HAD BREAKS IN
OUR SKILLED FACILITY I'M MORE I
THAN NOT THE END PAGE IS A
STAFF PERSON WITH A MY SYMPTOM.
OR EIGHT ABOUT AND WHO ALL KNOW
BRINGING OF COLD AND TWO PIECES.
HI THE CRITICAL AND- FREQUENT
TEST. OF STOCK ANOTHER UNDER
ISSUE THAT WE HAVE FOUND IS
THAT OF OUR OUT WORKER IS
INSTABILITY COM UM THIS TRINITY
THAT ARE COUNTY ARE JUST LOOK.
AND BY. AND SO THE SKILLED
FACILITY AND THEN WAYS ABOUT
THREE THE NEXT IN THE WAY THAT
AND IS IN OUR- AND CHEN. THANK
YOU AND THE I HAVE A HARD IT
TEN BUT I HOW TO STAY ON UNTIL
THE THANK YOU THANK YOU MUCH TO
CODE WE- THAT IN. WE'LL MOVE ON
TO OUR NEXT PRESENTER FOURTH
PRESENTER IS CRA THE C. E. O.
PRESS OF THE- SISSY OF HEALTH
FACILITIES WELCOME MISTER
CORNET. THANK LISTEN AND
MEMBERS OF THE CAN AIMS CRAIG
CORNET I'M S. OF THE- SAYS OF
HELP. YOUR TO REPRESENT THE
TWELVE HUNDRED- SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES IN CALIFORNIA- WHO
SERVED FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS EVERY DAY DISABLED
AND ELDERLY CALIFORNIANS EVERY
DAY- AND EMPLOY A HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND A CALIFORNIANS AS OUR
STAFF- IT'S UNUSUAL FOR ME TO
TESTIFY. THESE SETTINGS BUT I
WANTED TO THE REASON I WANTED
TO BE HERE TODAY IS TO TELL YOU
THE IMPORTANCE. AT AND HOW. WE
TAKE THESE ISSUES- I'M GOING TO
TELL YOU ABOUT THE- THE
PROBLEMS THAT THREE THINGS THE
PROBLEMS WE FACE. WHERE THINGS
STAND TODAY AND WHAT'S AHEAD. I
WANT TO START OUT AT THE SAID
BY BY TELLING YOU WE MOURN THE
VICTIMS OF THIS PANDA. OF
RESIDENCE. AND THE PATIENTS
THAT ARE THE ONLY. UP WITH.
PASS CODE WITH THAT IT STAFF
MARCUS SO OKAY FROM CO. FOR
THEIR FAMILIES THE MORE THE
MALL THIS IS BEEN JUST. FOR
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES BUT
IT'S BEEN DESTRUCTIVE THE ARE
REST AND I AM AND THE FAN OF
OUR RAY. AND FOR CARE GIVERS.
OUT OUTLINED FOR YOU QUICKLY.
THE PROBLEM FIVE PROBLEMS THAT
WE HAVE SEEN THUS FAR. FIRST OF
ALL NUMBER ONE KOBE NINETEEN
LIKE NOW WE'VE SEEN ENTER OF A
OF HAND THEM IN IN THIS. FOR
THAT IT IS FOR TWO. IT'S BEEN A
PARTICULARLY DIFFICULT FOR THE
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS IN
OUR SOCIETY WHICH ARE ELDERLY
AND PEOPLE WHO ARE HEALTH
COMPROMISED AND THAT IS A 100%
OF THE PEOPLE WHO. ARE OUR
RESIDENTS AND PATIENTS IN
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES.
NUMBER TWO THE INFORMATION
ABOUT THE VIRUS HAS CHANGED AND
CHANGED. WE'VE LEARNED FOR A-
LATE IN THE PROCESS A
SYMPTOMATIC PEOPLE- WHETHER
THEY BE RESIDENTS VISITORS ARE
CARE GIVERS. COULD ACTUALLY
THAT THEY COULD BE A
SYMPTOMATIC BUT COULD BE STILL
SPREADING THE VIRUS WITHOUT
SHOWING ANY SIGNS. OF THAT THAT
HAS BEEN A PART PROBLEM. WELL
INTO THE- JUST CHARGE FROM THE
HOSPITALRESIDENTS JUST FROM
THE HOSPITAL STAFF COMING IN
OUR VISITORS COMING- THEY WERE
SPREADING THE VIRUS BEFORE WE
KNEW THAT THAT WAS POSSIBLE-
AND SHOWING NO SIGN NUMBER
THREE. AND THAT'S WHEN I CAN'T
EMPHASIZE ENOUGH OF FROM THE
GET GO THERE HAS BEEN
INADEQUATE PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT WE KNOW NOW THAT.
PARTICULAR KINDS OF EQUIPMENT
ARE MOST IMPORTANT TO AVOID THE
SPREAD OF CODE. UNFORTUNATELY
NO ONE HAVE THAT EQUIPMENT THE
SUPPLY CHAINS WERE NOT
AVAILABLE- FACILITIES DIDN'T
HAVE IT THE COUNTIES DIDN'T
HAVE IT AND NO ONE REALLY HAD
IT AND THAT WAS A IT'S BEEN A
PARTICULAR PROBLEM- I NOTICED
IN YOUR IN YOUR- COMMITTEE ROB
WORK THAT WAS SOME NOTES. TAKE
NOTATE ABOUT MAKES HOME PP BUT
THE REASON THAT WAS IT WILL
AVAIL ADEQUATE PP WASN'T
AVAILABLE THAT WAS MOST
IMPORTANT TO AVOID THE SPREAD.
I OR I WOULD MENTION YOU AND
ALSO IS VERY. THERE HAS BEEN
ADDED IN ADEQUATE TESTING
TESTING HAS RAMPED UP VERY
NICELY MORE RECENTLY. THE
TESTING WAS NOT AVAILABLE AT
THE BEGINNING OF THIS PANDEMIC
AND THAT'S WHEN YOU REALLY NEED
IT AT A PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS
YOU NEED TESTING- IS O
CRITICAL- AND AT TO BE ABLE TO
KNOW WHO IS POSITIVE AND
ESPECIALLY THEN AFTER. THAT WE
CAN BE SPREADING THE DISEASE-
BUT THAT WAS NOT REALLY RATTLED
TESTING WAS NOT READILY
AVAILABLE UNTIL FAIRLY RECENTLY.
AND UP FIVE AND I'M I CAN'T
EMPHASIZE THIS ENOUGH. AT THE
BEGINNING OF THIS PANDEMIC THE
FOCUS AND THE EMPHASIS WAS
REALLY ON OUR HOSPITALS.
UNDERSTANDABLY SO THERE WAS A I
THOUGHT THE AT THAT POINT THE
MODELING WAS SHOWING WE MIGHT
NEED FORTY THOUSAND ADDITIONAL
HOSPITAL BEDS BEYOND WHAT WE
HAD. AND THE EMPHASIS AND FOCUS
WAS NOT ON SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES IT CAME LATER. AB
PRIORITY WAS PROVIDE INITIALLY
FOR PP AND FOR AYE TESTING WAS
IN THE HOSPITALS NOT AT NOT ON
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES THAT
HAS RESULTED DâN BY THE TIME
THE FOCUS DID TURN TO SKILLED
NURSING IT WAS ALMOST TOO LATE
THE DISEASE THAT ARE ENTERED
THE FACILITIES. AND IT WAS
SPREADING TO PLAY. IN ADDITION
I WOULD SAY TO BECAUSE OF THE
BECAUSE OF THE- EMPHASIS THERE
WERE CONFLICTS WAS CONFLICTING
STANDARDS AND FLIPPING. THAT I
THINK THAT HAVE EVERYWHERE APRS
GUIDANCE FROM FROM THE FEDERAL.
GUIDE FROM THE STAY GUIDES FROM
THE COUNTIES AND DIFFERENT
DIFFERENT GUIDANCE IN DIFFERENT
PLACES. SO THAT I THINK REALLY
REALLY HINDERED ARE SITUATION
ALL THE WAY AROUND. LET ME TURN
TO WHAT IS NEEDED NOW WHAT'S
NEEDED NOW I THINK IT'S SUPPORT
SUPPORT FROM FROM THE PUBLIC
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION THE
LEGISLATURE. WHAT I WOULD SAY
OUR FORESEES. COORDINATION
COLLABORATION COMMUNICATION AND
CONSISTENCY BETWEEN-
GOVERNMENTAL OVERSIGHT BODIES-
AND ASSISTANCE AGAIN FROM. FROM
PROVIDERS AND WOOD AND THE-
SOME READ REDUCTION OF THE
LOCAL VARIATION WE SEE- AGAIN
TESTING IS SO WEIRD WE ARE NOW
MOVING FORWARD ON TESTING BY
THE END OF THIS MONTH OFFICE.
WILL HAVE DONE BASELINE TESTING.
THE LADY SAID NOW RAMPED UP AND
HAVE MITIATION OF PLANTS
COMPLEX THAT CD PHP IS
CURRENTLY YOU. ARE I ALSO WOULD
TO WHAT IS REALLY- NEEDED NOW
IS TO RECOGNIZE THE FACTS AND
THE DATA- I THINK YOU HEARD
DOCTOR CODY SAY THIS BUT THE
MOST RECENT RESEARCH FROM ORIG
WE HAVE. THIRTY MORE SAY SORRY
TO INTERRUPT HAS TOLD US THAT
INDEPENDENT ANALYSIS THAT A
SENTIMENT SPREAD. STING WERE
REALLY THE MAIN FOR THE OUT AND
NOT SO MY- THAT LACK OF THE
HISTORY THE BUILDING OF THE
FALL. OF THANK YOU I LOOK
FORWARD TO DIALOGUE WITH THE
LEAD TO ON THIS THE OTHER
THINGS I WOULD JUST CLOSE IF WE
WILL BELIEVE THAT IS WE DO HAVE
QUESTIONS- THEREAFTER SO WE'LL
GO AHEAD AND JUST WE HAVE TO
MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT. PRESENTER
I'M SORRY THAT BUT THINK YOU
VERY MUCH- AND THEN OUR FINAL
CENTER IS TONY CHICKEN TELL
STAFF ATTORNEY AT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
NURSING HOME REFORM. WELCOME
MISTER CHICKEN TELL THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE AS WELL. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR GONZALEZ AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR INVITING
ME TO SPEAK TODAY. MY NAME IS
TONY CHECK ITSELF- STAFF
ATTORNEY WITH CALIFORNIA AND
THE KIDS FOR NURSING HOME
REFORM ALSO KNOWN AS SCANNER. I
AM TESTIFYING TODAY ON BEHALF
OF NURSING HOME RESIDENTS.
RESIDENTS AROUND THE STATE ARE
SCARED ANGRY AND FRUSTRATED. WE
NEED TO LEARN FROM WHAT IS
HAPPENING TO IMPROVE LONG TERM
CARE IS NOT BLEEDING OR
PUNISHING WHEN WE EXAMINE
SYSTEMIC WEAK POINTS FAILURES
IT'S FOR FILLING OUR PUBLIC
COMMITMENTS TO ASSESS AND TO
GROW. WHAT TO THE DEVASTATION
IN NURSING HOMES HAS BEEN
AVOIDABLE. WE HAVE HAD DECADES
OF PEOPLE STATE LEADERSHIP AND
HALF HEARTED ENFORCEMENT GBH.
WE HAVE A PUBLIC PAYMENT
STRUCTURE THAT DIVIDES
FACILITIES INTEREST FROM
RESIDENTS INTEREST. WE'VE
CREATED THE ENVIRONMENT IN
WHICH PANDEMICS WILL KILL
NURSING HOME RESIDENTS WITH.
THAT. WHEN COLBERT HIDDEN- SING
RESIDENTS AND STAFF WERE
SACRIFICED IN FAVOR OF OTHER
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS AND
PATIENTS. THERE WERE MANY FATAL
MISSTEPS. ONE SURVEY YEARS
OMBUDSMAN AND FAMILIES WERE
EXCLUDED FROM FACILITIES
CREATING A MASSIVE LOSS OF
OVERSIGHT AND DIRECT HERE. SOME
OF THE WORST DISABILITIES IN
THE STATE OF BEING DESIGNATED
AS COVERT NINETEEN FACILITY.
SINCE MARCH CALIFORNIA HAS
PERFORMED OVER ONE THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED AND FACTION
CONTROL SURVEYS IN DID NOT
ISSUE A SINGLE INFECTION
CONTROL DEFICIENCY. AS A
RESULT. THE SURVEYORSWERE TOLD
NOT TO ISSUE DEFICIENCIES AND
GET CLEAN BILLS OF HEALTH
STORIES AROUND THE PROCESS.
RANGING ENORMOUS COOLEY
NINETEEN OPERATE. NOWWE HAVE
TWO THOUSAND RESIDENTS DEAD
OVER TWO THOUSAND. TEN THOUSAND
RESIDENTS IMPACTED IN ALMOST
SIX THOUSAND STAFF MEMBERS. WE
GET THEOUTCOME OUR SYSTEM IS
DESIGNED TO PROVIDE THERE ARE
NO SURPRISES HERE WELL BEFORE
COLLUDED TO CDC ESTIMATES THAT
THREE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY EIGHT
HOURS IN LONG TERM CARE
RESIDENTS DIE ANNUALLY. FROM
INFECTIOUS DISEASE IN OUR
COUNTRY. WE PUT OUR SICKEST
MOST REAL PEOPLE INTEREST
CROWDED BUILDINGS WITH
INSUFFICIENT STAFFING RUN BY
BUSINESS PEOPLE WHOSE ULTIMATE
GOAL IS NOT TO PROVIDE GOOD
CARE BUT TO TAKE PROFITS FUNDED
BY TAXPAYERS. INCREDIBLY
PROVIDING GOOD CARE IS NOT A
LINE PROFITABILITY. THIS IS NOT
JUST FACT IT IS THE PRODUCT OF
DESIGN. THE VAST MAJORITY OF
NURSING REVENUE COMES FROM THE
GOVERNMENT THE GOVERNMENT HAS
PROVEN TO BE AN IMPULSE
SHOPPER. USING ITS HEART AND
NOT ITS HEAD WHEN SHOVELS OVER
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS EVERY YEAR
HIS VOICE STEVEN ENORMOUS NO
STRINGS ATTACHED REYES THIS
MONTH. KANTOR HAS SUBMITTED A
TEN POINT PLAN FOR STATEWIDE
LONG TERM CARE REFORM. YOUR
SOME OF OUR MOST IMPORTANT
RECOMMENDATION. RELATED TO
UNFORTUNATE ACCOUNTABILITY
ENFORCEMENT IS WEAK ONCE AGAIN
STARS IN HOMES OF EXPLODED
VIOLATIONS LIKE BAD INFECTION
CONTROL ARE COMMONPLACE BUT ARE
NOT DISCOURAGED BECAUSE OF A
LACK OF FINE. 99% OF INFECTION
CONTROL VIOLATIONS ARE CALLED
NO HARM. PROVIDERS OF STOCK
BLANKET IMMUNITYFOR WRONGDOERS
YOU CAN CONNECT GROSS
NEGLIGENCE THE CAUSE OF DEATH.
WHAT WE NEED WHAT WE ARE LONG
NEEDED THIS TRUMP TOWER
RESIDENTS AND VICTIMS OF POOR
CARE TO DO THEIR OWN
ENFORCEMENT. EVH IS PROVEN FOR
DECADES AND THEY CAN'T GET THIS
DROPPED OUT. STABBING OUR
MINIMUM STAFFING STANDARDS ARE
TO LOWER OFTEN VIOLATED. NEED
TO RAISE THE STABBING MINIMUMS
PARTICULARLY FOR REGISTERED
NURSES. AND DUMP THE WAIVERS
AGAIN FACILITIES A PAST PROVIDE
LESS STANDING THE MINIMUM.
THERE'S BUDGET LEGISLATION
RIGHT NOW WITH THE SIMPLE
REFORMS COULD BE AT. OWNERSHIP
OUR WORST OPERATORS TAKEOVER
NURSING HOMES WITHOUT LICENSES
AND SLOT THERE AND PROFIT FOR
YEARS. THROW OUT THESE
OPERATORS YOU DON'T HAVE
LICENSES. THE HOLES IN THE
OWNERSHIP FOR APPROVAL PROCESS
HAVE BEEN EXPLOITED MERCILESS
THE NCD PH IS DONE NOTHING
ABOUT IT. BUDGET OUR PUBLIC
RESOURCES THE HOME AND
COMMUNITY BASED SETTINGS AND
AWAY FROM HERS. IN OTHER WORDS
YOU THE OPPOSITE OF WHAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS PROPOSED IN HIS
BUDGET. EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS.
WE NOW HAVE A PANDEMIC
COLLIDING WITH WILDFIRES SEIZE.
THE SENATE WILL SOON VOTE ON
SENATOR JACKSON'S SB TWELVE AU
SEVEN. WHICH WILL ENSURE STATE
COMPLIANCE WITH THE FEDERAL
STANDARD. THEY'RE ALL NURSING
HOMES HAVE AT LEAST NINETY SIX
HOURS OF BACKUP POWER TO KEEP
RESIDENTS SAFE DURING THE
BLACKOUT. I URGE THE MEMBERS TO
VOTE YES ON THIS VERY SIMPLE
BUT IMPORTANT AT ALL. THERE'S A
TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY HERE TO
CHANGE THE WAY WE PROVIDE LONG
TERM CARE THE STATE AND IMPROVE
THE QUALITY OF LIFE OF
THOUSANDS. HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE. THIS
PANDEMIC IS NOT BROKEN THE
SYSTEM IT IS REVEALED THAT. THE
SYSTEM DOES NOT PRIORITIZE
PRESIDENT EXPERIENCE. RESIDENTS
ARE BYSTANDERS INTO OFTEN BIG.
THINGS TO CHANGE. BERNIE
SANDERS INTERESTED IN REFORM I
URGE YOU TO CONTACT ME. LET'S
GET TO WORK. THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE. IT'S AN
HONOR TO SPEAK FOR RESIDENTS.
WERE IN SURGERY NEED OF COMFORT
AND- HI. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHICKEN TELL WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY ALSO-
SO THANK YOU TO ALL THE
PRESENTERS FOR BEING HERE AND
BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO MEMBER
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS I WOULD
LIKE TO ONCE AGAIN INVITE. OF
THE PUBLIC WOULD LIKE TO
PARTICIPATE TO CALL IN NOW.
PLEASE DIAL THIS TOLL FREE
NUMBER AGAIN THIS IS. ONE EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. AGAIN THAT'S
844-291-6364 AND WHEN PROMPTED
PLEASE USE ACCESS CODE SIX
THREE TWO. SIX EIGHT THREE ZERO
AGAIN THAT IS ACCESS CODE SIX
THREE TWO. SIX EIGHT THREE
ZERO. THANK YOU AND I WILL
ACTUALLY BEGIN WITH THE VERY
FIRST QUESTION AND I THINK
AGAIN OUR PANELISTS FOR BEING
HERE- WE'RE CERTAINLY DEEPLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE NUMBERS
THAT WE'VE SEEN HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
ALTHOUGH- WE MAY BE A MODEL FOR
OTHER STATES IF I FEEL THERE'S
A LOT OF WORK THAT WE NEED TO
DO HERE. AND BEING A MEMBER OF
LA COUNTY- I KNOW AND IN THIS
IS BOTH FOR LA COUNTY AND FOUR
CD PH I KNOW THAT LA COUNTY HAS
ITS OWN CERTIFICATION AND
LICENSING PROCESS- BUT SIMILAR
TO THE- ACTION TAKEN BY THE LA
COUNTY SUPERVISORS WE HAD A
BACKLOG OF ABOUT FIVE THOUSAND-
SNF- INVESTIGATIONS. LAST
YEAR'S I'D LIKE TO KIND OF WALK
THROUGH HOW THOSE BACKLOGS. ARE
LOOKING NOW AND WHAT THE LONG
TERM SOLUTION IS FOR. ON THIS
INSPECTOR GENERAL NOW BEING A
PART OF THIS. THE PROP. FIGURES
TO LIMIT. YOU'RE STILL ON ME
WILL MAKE SURE YOU GET MUTED
RIGHT NOW. A NEED. OKAY CAN YOU
HEAR ME NOW YES WE CAN DR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MADAM
CHAIR FOR YOUR QUESTION WE ARE
AWARE OF THE BACKLOG IN THE IN
THE INVESTIGATIONS- OUR PRIMARY
FOCUS IS GOING FORWARD TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE NEED TO
REQUIREMENTS- THAT HAVE BEEN
SPECIFIED TO US BY THE STATE
OUT OF THE CONTRACT WHICH IS
YOU KNOW PERFORMING THE ANNUAL
ASSESSMENTS. RECEIVING THE
COMPLAINTS AND ALSO THERE'S
OTHER- REPORTS THAT ARE
GENERATED FROM THE FACILITIES
THAT WE HAVE TO INVESTIGATE
THAT'S OUR FIRST TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT WORK IS COMPLETED
GOING OVER. WE ARE LOOKING AT
THE BACKLOG IS. WE'LL DO OUR
BEST. TO RIP. A RELIEF THAT
I'LL HAVE TO GET BACK WITH YOU
WITH MORE INFORMATION EXACTLY
ON THE TIME LINE FOR THAT AS I
DON'T HAVE THAT INFORMATION
FRONT OF ME. BUT I KNOW WE ARE
WORKING ON THAT. THANK YOU
DOCTOR YES A TIME LINE WOULD BE
MOST APPRECIATED- ESPECIALLY
GIVEN THE FACT THAT WE MAY SEE
A RESEARCH IN THE FALL AND SO
WE WOULD LIKE TO. ABSOLUTELY
HAVE MORE INFORMATION I
APPRECIATE THAT. AND IS THERE
ANY ADDITIONAL INFORMATION THAT
YOU CAN ADD FROM CITY P. H.
ABOUT. LA COUNTY AND HOW WE CAN
PROVIDE MORE RESOURCES TO AREAS
AS BIG AS LA COUNTY ESPECIALLY
WITH OUR OWN LICENSING PROCESS.
HI YES THIS IS HEIDI STEINER
PERSONAL CD PH YES SIR WHEN I
WAS APPOINTED HERE DECEMBER
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. FOR QUICKLY
DISCOVERED THAT WE DO HAVE TO
EAT. A LARGE BACKLOG MAINLY IN
LA COUNTY BUT HE WAS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE AND WE DID A DEEP
DIVE AND ACTUALLY HAD A WHOLE
PROJECT ON THIS LAST YEAR OF
LOOKING AT WHAT WERE SOME OF
THE ROOT CAUSES AND THERE WERE
SEVERAL ROOT CAUSES AND IT WAS
NOT. YOU KNOW LA COUNTIES- I
DON'T WANT IT IT WASN'T ANY
BLAME TO BE IT BUT HE WAS
REALLY LOOKING AT HOW DID BE
CONTRACTUALLY GET YOUR WE
WEREN'T ACTUALLY CONTRACTING
FOR THE AMOUNT OF WORK LOAD AND
LOOKS DOING TIME STUDIES THAT
HAVE HAPPENED. SO WHAT WE DID
IS WE PUT TO GET ABLE TO PROVE
IT MANAGEMENT AND- IT'S CALLED
DEBT TWENTY FREE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE- TO REDUCE THE DEBT BY.
WORRY TWENTY NINE WITH THE
ORIGINAL GOAL IN MY DE SECOND
QUARTER NOW SINCE WE HAD THE
PANDEMIC HOWEVER. OR THE
PANDEMIC HERE WE WERE CLOSE TO
A- IN JUST OF MY AFTER WE HAD
INPUT. ALREADY PRODUCTS. I'M
INSTREAM. CREATING MORE
CONSISTENT PRACTICES ACROSS THE
BOARD WE ACTUALLY HAD A
REDUCTION OF 23% OF OUR BACKLOG
COMPLAINT BACKLOG. I CHECKED ON
IT YESTERDAY- BUT BECAUSE IT IN
TAKES AND- OTHER WORK THAT
WE'VE AFFECTS SEEN ON I THINK
WE'RE NOW AT ABOUT TWENTY ONE
PERCENT. REDUCTION OF OUR
OVERALL BACKLOG. BUT WE ARE
GOING FULL FORCE WITH GOING
BACK WITH THOSE PLANS THAT WE
PUT IN PLACE- BACK THROUGH
JANUARY FEBRUARY- THE AND WE
HAD A WHOLE PLAN IN PLACE IT
WAS ALSO APPROVED BY CMS IN IT
WE WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS ON.
LAND SO- WE'RE AWARE OF IT AND
WEHAVE ALREADY MADE
SIGNIFICANT STRIDES TOWARD
REDUCING NAPA. I THINK THAT ONE
OF OUR STRATEGIES GOING FORWARD
ALSO FROM THIS KIND OF WHICH IS
THAT MOBILE. APPS THAT I WAS
DESCRIBING YOU MEAN OUR OUR
WORK ELECTRONICALLY SO THAT NOT
ONLY IS THAT GREATER
TRANSPARENCY FOR STAKEHOLDERS
IN OUR LOVED ONES OUT THERE ARE
LOOKING TO SEE WHAT IS BEING
FOUND AT THESE FACILITIES. BUT
USING THE MOBILE APP AND THE
ELECTRONIC AUTOMATED ON DESKTOP
THAT FORMED. BECAUSE RIGHT NOW
WE'RE DOING A LOT OF OUR WORK
THROUGH PAPER AND MANUAL
PROCESSES SO BY UPDATING OUR
SYSTEM. I'M TO BE MORE
AUTOMATED- AND BE ABLE TO HAVE-
USE TECHNOLOGY WILL BE ABLE TO
GO THROUGH THE BILL TO GO
OUTSIDE BE ABLE TO GET
INFORMATION BACK. IT'S
DISABILITIES AS WELL AS BE ABLE
TO GET BACK TO THOSE- WHO
INTERESTED PARTIES WHO WANT TO
HAVE THAT INFORMATION SO.
THAT'S THE BEST UPDATE THAT I
HAVE A FIRST LINE AS WELL AS
WITH STRATEGIES FOR USING.
THANK YOU AND JUST FOLLOW UP
THERE IS THIS THE- WE'RE JUST
TALKING ABOUT LICENSED
FACILITIES DO WE HAVE ANY DATA
ON UNLICENSED. FACILITIES AND
WHAT WE ARE DOING TO. ADDRESS
FIRST THE UNLICENSED PART. AND
SECONDLY THE- DEEP CONCERNS
THAT WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING HERE
AS- ANALYSTS. SO WE CAN. THE
LIGHTS FACILITIES FOR
CALIFORNIA IN CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE ABOUT ELEVEN THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY NINE LICENSED
FACILITIES THOSE THE FACILITIES
THAT DPH. HAS OVERSIGHT FOR BUT
THE COMPLAINTS AND FACILITY
REPORTED INCIDENTS AS WELL AS
THE QUALITY AND SAFETY
OVERSIGHT- BY THE WAY I DID
DOUBLE CHECK YESTERDAY NIGHT
ACTUALLY. ACCORDING TO THE CMS
THE CEOS. BETWEEN OF THE- AND
JUNE THIRD WE GAVE OVER THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY CITATIONS IN
OVER A HUNDRED AND FIFTY NINE
FACILITIES AND A HUNDRED AND
THIRTEEN OF THEM. PAUL RELATED
WE ALL ISSUED OUT SERVE IN NEED
JEOPARDY. OF WHICH IS THE
HARSHEST PENALTY FROM THE
FEDERAL SIDE- THAT WE CAN GET
UP AND STATE ON SITE TO MAKE
SURE THE EITHER THOSE IDEAS
WERE. ABATED THREE CORRECTIONS-
OR WE ALSO TAKE NEXT STEPS IF
NEEDED IF THE FACILITY IS NO
LONGER ABLE TO. QUALITY OF CARE.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR OF
THE ANSWERS WE APPRECIATE THAT
AND WE'LL MOVE ON TO SENATOR
JACKSON. NOT SURE HAVE. THIS IS
WORKING THIS IS THE BEST WAY TO
DO IT SHOULD I STAND TO AYE
WHATEVER YOU'D LIKE TO DO THAT
GO GO RIGHT AHEAD WELL YOU
SOUND GOOD THERE UNLESS YOU
WANT TO STAND UP. MIGHT BE. UP
TO STAND UP BECAUSE THE MIKE
DOESN'T WANT TO COME DOWN TO MY
SHORT LEVEL- FIRST I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF YOU I KNOW THIS IS
HAS BEEN A VERY DIFFICULT
CIRCUMSTANCE- TO ALL OF OUR
WITNESSES WHO TESTIFY ALSO WANT
TO THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR
BRINGING THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE
TO THE FOR OUR- THE- BE FOR
THOUGH I GET TO MY QUESTION- I.
I WANT TO PERSONALLY THANK ALL
OF OUR- HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS I SHARE WITH MY
GOOD COLLEAGUE. SENATOR DR PAN
CONCERNS ABOUT THE ATTACKS
BEING MADE ON OUR HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS. WHOSE JOB IT IS-TO TRY TO KEEP US HEALTHY- AND
I WANT TO GIVE A PARTICULAR
SHOT OUT TO DOCTOR CODY. DOES
NOT THINK RIGHT. THE FOR THE
FUNDAMENTAL. OF WHY ARE WE RE
OPENING OUR SOCIETY WOULD. HAVE
YOUR A VACCINE AND NO TREATMENT
FOR COVE OF NINETEEN. AND NEED
TO BE CAUTIOUS I KNOW DOCTOR
FAUCI IS ALSO EXPRESSED
CONCERNS- BUT I KNOW DOCTOR
CODY HAS BEEN A VERY VERY
STRONG AND I THINK POWERFUL- IF
NOT EFFECTIVE VOICE- BECAUSE AS
OBVIOUSLY WE'RE SEEING THINGS
REOPEN WE'RE SEEING SPIKING IN
CASES- BUT I AM I APPRECIATE
HER COURAGE AND HER PASSION AND
HER WILLINGNESS. TO TAKE ON-
SOME OF THE POWERFUL FORCES I
SUSPECT MOST OF THEM ARE YOU
NAMIK. BUT IN KEEPING WITH HER
RESPONSIBILITIES AS A PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICER TO BE AS
CAUTIOUS AND IS HONEST ABOUT
THE SITUATION. WHERE SHE HAS
BEEN AND SO I DID PERSONALLY IN
BOTH ON BEHALF OF MY-
CONSTITUENTS WANT TO THANK HER.
OF A PERSONALLY FOR HER
EFFORTS. MY QUESTION- I AM
FAMILIAR WITH THE FACT THAT.
THE AT THE EARLIEST STAGES OF
THIS FOR A PANDEMIC IT UNITED
STATES ARE. CONGREGATE CARE
FACILITIES HAVE BEEN THE MOST-
HARSHLY. IMPACTED AND OF COURSE
THAT INCLUDES OUR NURSING HOMES
IN PARTICULAR. IN THE DISCUSS
IT WAS CLEAR THAT EARLY ON IN
THIS APPLIES I THINK NOT CHARGE
TO OUR NURSING HOMES BUT TO ALL
FACETS OF OUR EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS THIS. VIRUS THERE WAS A
LACK OF UNDERSTANDING OF THERE
WAS A LACK OF TESTING A LACK OF
PPVS. AND AS A RESULT WE SAW A
NUMBER OF OUR HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONALS AND FIRST
RESPONDERS- THE PARISH AS A
RESULT- AND WE SO I HAVE SEEN
SO MANY OF OUR SENIORS AND SO
MANY PEOPLE IN. NURSING CARE
FACILITIES ARE ALSO DIE FROM
THIS FARCE- WE NOW HAVE AS I
UNDERSTAND THE CONVERSATION WE
HAVE IMPROVED ACCESS TO P. B.
EASE WE ARE UNDERSTAND A LITTLE
BIT BETTER ABOUT. WHAT HOW THIS
VIRUS TRANSMITS IN THE A
SYMPTOMATIC NATURE THAT MAKES A
PARTICULARLY INSIDIOUS- I'M
WONDERING IF A DOCTOR CODY
PERHAPS IF YOU COULD START
BECAUSE I KNOW YOU HAVE TO
LEAVE SHORTLY. COULD TELL US AS
A RESULT OF THE CHANGES-
WHETHER YOU BELIEVE THAT WILL
SEE FEWER DEATHS. ARE COMING
FROM OUR NURSING HOMES AND
FEWER DEATHS IN GENERAL BECAUSE
WORLD WEARING MASKS AND SOME
PEOPLE ARE WORRIED ASSN THE
RIGHT TO MAINTAIN. PHYSICAL
DISTANCING YOU SEE OUR- THE
POTENTIAL REDUCTION IN THE
NUMBER OF DEATHS IN THEIR HOME
TO AN IN GENERAL AS A RESULT
THE STEPS THAT HAVE BEEN TAKEN
ALONG WITH THE TESTING. ATTEMPT
TO TRACE- AND SO TOO CAN FIND
PEOPLE WHO HAVE TESTED. WOULD
POSITIVELY. THANK THANK YOU SO
MUCH SO MUCH FOR YOUR QUESTION
I'LL DO MY BEST TO ANSWER I
THINK THAT- ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT WAYS THAT WE CAN
PROTECT. RESIDENTS IN SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY. IS THROUGH
TESTING AND WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO THERE OF COURSE. IS
PREVENTION OF THE INTRODUCTION
OF INFECTION INTO CONGREGATE
SETTINGS WHERE REALLY EVERYONE
THERE. IS AT RISK. AND BECAUSE
AS WAS MENTIONED EARLIER WE'VE
LEARNED SO MUCH ABOUT THIS
VIRUS AND WE NOW UNDERSTAND THE
ROLE OF ASYMPTOMATIC
TRANSMISSION- THAT IS MORE
IMPORTANT FOR AB THAT THAN
EVER. I ALSO JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT AGAIN DIE MANY OF THE
STAFF WHO AT LEAST WORK AND
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES AND
OUR JURISDICTION- J. ARE AMONG.
LOW WAGE WORKERS THEY COME FROM
COMMUNITIES WHERE WE'RE SEEING
A LOT OF TRANSMISSION OF COAL
BED. AND SO IT IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT THAT THEY BE- TESTED
FREQUENTLY THAT WE REMOVE
BARRIERS TO TESTING- SO THAT
THEY CAN DO THEIR WORK AND
PROTECT BOTH THEMSELVES AND THE
RESIDENTS THAT THEY CARE FOR SO
I THINK- THE REALLY IMPORTANT
COLOR. PREVENT THAT AND OF
COURSE. ADEQUATE P. P. AS WELL-
SO THOSE ARE THE LAYERS OF THE
LAYERS OF PROTECTION BUT I
THINK OUR I HAVE BEEN A REALLY
PROTECT- THE RESIDENTS OF BEST-
AS BEST WE CAN SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU DOCTOR CODY UP
DID YOU HAVE ANOTHER QUESTION
SENATOR JACKSON AYE I DID OKAY
THE OTHER QUESTION GOES MORE TO
THE FINAL TWO SPEAKERS MISTER
CORNET AND- MISTER CHECK COULD
TELL. MOM IT SEEMS IN READING
THE EXCELLENT BACK FROM PAPER
AND IN MY EXPERIENCE ACTUALLY
TRYING TO. ADDRESS SOME OF THE-
PROBLEMS ASSOCIATED WITH
NURSING HOMES AND NURSING CARE-
WE HAVE A SORT OF A STRUCTURAL
PROBLEM AND AS WAS MENTIONED
THAT. THE PAYMENT AND THE CARE
ARE ALMOST OF OPPOSITE.
CONCERNS OF THESE FACILITIES
GET MORE MONEY FOR NEW PATIENTS
THAN THEY DO FOR THE ONES THEY
ARE AND THE US OF COURSE IN THE
COVERT SHOULD SHOULD CONTEXT OF
THE POTENTIAL FOR BRINGING IN
COVERT POSITIVE PATIENTS IS A
AN INDUCEMENT- AND OF COURSE
WITH URSING HOMES IN GENERAL-
I AGREE THAT FOR DECADES WE
HAVE BEEN EXTRAORDINARILY
LAPSE. IN OUR PROTECTION ALL OF
OUR MOST VULNERABLE OF
POPULATION BEING OUR SENIORS
AND THOSE WHO HAVE HEALTH
ISSUES- I'M WONDERING IF YOU
EITHER OF YOU HAVE A
SUGGESTION. AS TO HOW WE
LITERALLY CHANGE A SYSTEM THAT
HAS UNDERFUNDED THESE HOPE
HOMES MOST OF WHICH ARE FOR
PROFIT AND THEY WANT TO MAKE
MONEY THAT'S THEIR PRIMARY AND-
FREQUENTLY THEIR EXCLUSIVE
GOAL- AS PROFIT MAKING END OF
ENTERPRISES. THE ROLE OF
GOVERNMENT OF COURSE IS TO
REGULATE AND PROTECT AGAINST
ABUSES IN THEIR PROCESS. AND
I'M WONDERING IF EITHER OR BOTH
OF THEM HAVE SOME SUGGESTIONS
POSITIVE SUGGESTIONS THAT WE
COULD AND SHOULD CONSIDER TO
REALLY TRY TO TURN THIS AROUND
IN THE IN THE COVERT IN POST
COVERT WORLD AHEAD. THANK YOU
SENATOR JACKSON I THINK THAT
WAS DIRECTED TOWARDS A TONY
CHICKEN TELL AND CREEK CORNET.
TONY YEAH THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTION SENATOR JACKSON'S THIS
KIND OF GETS RIGHT AT THE HEART
OF WHAT I'VE BEEN DOING FOR THE
LAST TWENTY YEARS I'M THINKING
ABOUT LONG TERM SOLUTIONS TO
THESE VERY SYSTEMIC PROBLEMS.
I'M I THINK I WOULD RECOMMEND
TWO THINGS ONE. I THINK OUR
LAWS OR REGULATIONS ARE
ACTUALLY PRETTY DARN GOOD IN
CALIFORNIA. THEY'RE VERY
PROTECTIVE OF RESIDENTS AND
THEY ESTABLISH I THINK A- GOOD.
MINIMUM STANDARD OF CARE.
PROBLEM IS ALWAYS BEEN
ENFORCEMENT. PERSON AS I
MENTIONED IN MY TESTIMONY HAS
BEEN LAX FOR DECADES IT'S BEEN
TOLERANCE OF VIOLATIONS OF MEAN
EVERY ALMOST EVERY FACILITY IN
THE STATE HAS MULTIPLE
VIOLATIONS ANYTIME IT'S- JUST.
IT JUST BOUNCES ALONG CONTINUE
THAT WAY- THE FAILURES ARE NOT
CORRECTED IN THE LONG RUN SO I
THINK. A SIGNIFICANT FOCUSED
ON. GOOD AFFECTED ENFORCEMENT
THAT NOT ONLY INCLUDES A
REGULATORS BUT AS I MENTIONED
MY TESTIMONY THE RESIDENTS. OF
THE RESIDENTS MORE POWER TO
ENFORCE THE STANDARDS OF. THE
PIE BUT THEY LIVE UNDER-
DIRECTLY RATHER THAN RELYING ON
OTHER PEOPLE TO DO BEFORE THE%
OUTSOURCING. NEVER SAY EVEN
MAYBE A LONG TERM. IS TO BRING
THE- VOICE IN THE PRESIDENT X.
INTO THE VALUATION OF THE CARE
THAT'S GIVEN- RIGHT NOW.
RESIDENTS GENERALLY DON'T OR
THEY PAY VERY LITTLE FOR THEIR
OWN CAN'T IT'S MOSTLY
GOVERNMENT FUNDED BY TAXPAYERS.
AND SO THERE'S THIS MIDDLE
PERSON IN THE WAY BETWEEN. THE
RECEIPT OF CARE AND THE PAYMENT
FOR CARE. AND SO THE GOVERNMENT
PAYS FOR CARE SORT OF BLINDLY
NOT KNOWING WHETHER THE CARE
THAT WAS DELIVERED BECAUSE THEY
ARE NOT. IN THE RESIDENTS WHO
REALLY IN THE FAMILIES KNOW
WITH. THEY ARE NOT LOOKING HAVE
A STAKE IN AND HOW. OF THE
PERFORMANCES REWARDED. WRITING
ALIGNING THE REST EXPERIENCE
MORE WITH THE PAYMENT SYSTEM IS
SHOULD BE A PRIORITY. THANK YOU
AND NEXT WE'LL MOVE ON TO CRAIG
FOR ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
COMMENTS. CREEK IN YOU AND ME
ALL RIGHT THERE YOU ARE THANK
YOU THINK ABOUT THAT- YES AND
THANK YOU SENATOR JACKSON FOR
THE QUESTION- I WOULD POINT OUT
A COUPLE OF THINGS- TO YOU ON
THIS FIRST OF ALL IS YOU'VE
HEARD- SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES ARE UNIQUE AND THAT
THEY ARE ALMOST ALMOST A 100%
GOVERNMENT. HEY THE 866% ABOUT
ABOUT TWO THIRDS OF THE MONEY
COMES FROM MEDI CAL AND IS YOU
KNOW THE MEDI CAL RATES HAVE
BEEN A TORY SLEEP TO LOVE- AND
THAT THAT'S BEEN ONE OF THE
REAL PROBLEMS IT IS GETTING
ENOUGH- OF MONEY INTO THE
SYSTEM- FOR IT. TO ENHANCE IT I
WOULD SAY HOWEVER HE- THOUGH
THE NEXT THE NEW REIMBURSEMENT
STRUCTURE THAT IS- IS- INCLUDED
IN IN THE STATE BUDGET THIS
YEAR I THINK MAKE THOSE A LONG
WAY GOVERNOR DESERVES CREDIT
FOR WHAT HE'S DONE HERE. I HE
HAS I IN THE OUT YEARS- THE
INCREASES IN THE RATES THAT
WILL BE PAID TO QUALITY. SO IN
OTHER WORDS TO. TIED TO JUST TO
FULLY. GET THE ADDITIONAL MONEY
IN THE OUT YEARS. OF FACILITIES
WOULD HAVE TO MEET QUALITY
STANDARDS- EACH YEAR WHICH WE
FULLY SUPPORT THE PROFESSION
FULLY SUPPORTS THAT- TO
INCREASE QUALITY- EACH EACH AND
EVERY YEAR I THINK THAT'S
THAT'S- THAT'S IMPORTANT THAT.
WE DID OUT. YEAH BUT ALSO JUST
POINT OUT TO YOU THAT- ON THE
ENFORCEMENT SIDE. AND YOU HAVE
A- CONVERSATION ON THE BACKLOG.
GONZALEZ RAISE THE QUESTION ON
THE ON THE BACKLOG IN THE
ENFORCEMENT ISSUES. UP THE
PROFESSION FULY SUPPORTS. ALSO
GETTING RID OF THOSE THAT
BACKLOG OF COMPLAINTS- IT IT'S
GOOD FOR EVERYONEAND WE
SUPPORT WHAT THE STATE IS DOING
IN THAT BATTLE. THE STATEMENT
COUNTY LA COUNTY YOU'RE DOING
IT AT ARENA. I WOULD POINT OUT
TO YOU THAT OF THE BACK.
COMPLAINTS OF ALL COMPLAINTS
THE CLINTON. PERSON BECAUSE THE-
ABOUT HALF OF THEM. ARE SELF
REPORTS. STILL THE LEAST OF.
HAPPY WHAT AND THAT THAT IS THE
SISTERS AS A COMPLAINT WE'D
LIKE TO SEE ALL THE COMPLAINTS
I DEALT WITH THIS PLACE BUT I
THINK THE MOST OF THING IS TO
SUPPORT A FUNDING AND I AS I
SAID THE GOT THE GOVERNOR'S
FINANCING STRUCTURE. AT QUALITY.
OKAY THANK YOU IN CENTER
JACKSON I THINK SHE'S DONE WITH
HER QUESTIONS WILL MOVE ON TO
SENATOR PAN. I THANK YOU SO
MUCH MADAM CHAIR- SO AGAINST ON
THANK ALL THE PANELISTS FOR THE
PRESENTATION- WE SORT OF TALKED
A BIT ABOUT- LOOKING BACKWARDS
AND- RECOGNIZING THE CHALLENGES
OF HAD WITH- LACK OF P. P. AND
TESTING- I APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR AS- NOW IN THE STATE
IS PROPOSE THAT. WE DO REGULAR
TESTING- AND- SNIFFS- IT WAS TO
ENSURE WE IDENTIFY PEOPLE WHO
MIGHT. HAVE THE INFECTION THE
TERMS OF MOVING FORWARD I THINK
A IN MY OPENING REMARKS I
MENTIONED THAT WE HAVE IN LIKE
A LITTLE RIGHT WE ARE HAVING A
RISING SPACES- THERE'S ALSO
BEEN CONCERNED THATIN THE
FALL. WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A
SIMULTANEOUS ARISE POTENTIALLY
OF CORONA VIRUS BECAUSE THESE
POTENTIAL SEASONALITY TO SOME
QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT BUT
CERTAINLY AND COMBINED WITH
INFLUENZA. AS WELL- SO THE
USUAL FLU SEASON AS WELL SO. AS
WE ARE NOW FIRST OF ALL OPENING
UP WHICH MEANS IT'S GOING TO
GREATER DEMAND FOR P. D. E. SO
YOU SEE THE INCREASING FACES
OPPOSITION CAN BE MORE DEMAND
FOR FIFTY BY HAAS. IN OTHER
TÁI OF I'M IN TEXAS SO IT IS
BUT LOCATE. WILL MORE E. IF
THEY'RE GOING TO BE OPENING UP
TO PER. THE WORKERS AND THEIR
CUSTOMERS. HOW ARE WE SURE THAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE SUFFICIENT
PP MOVING FORWARD ON AN ONGOING
BASIS AND AGAIN APPRECIATE
THAT. MANDY MINISTRATION STEPS
TO TRY TO SECURE A MORE
RELIABLE SUPPLY PT. CRUISER
CONFIDENCE WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
SUFFICIENT PP FOR ALL OF OUR
NURSING HOME RESIDENTS AS WELL
AS THE STAFF FOR WORKING THERE
AND THEY FOR. SOME STILL THIRD
FROM SONS- STAFF- DATA
REPRESENT IS THE STAFF THAT-
DAY THEY STILL HAVE SOME
CHALLENGES OF P. E. SO. HOW WE
DOING TO ENSURE THAT THEY'RE
SUFFICIENT SUPPLY OF TV AND BY
THE WAY EVERY TIME WE DO A TEST
DON'T HAVE. TV AS WELL SO CAN
PERHAPS THE PUBLIC HEALTH AND
PERHAPS MISTER CORNET. CAN
SPEAK TO THE- INSURANCE P. E.
GOING INTO THE FUTURE- IT FOR
ALL OUR NURSING HOME FACILITIES
HERE FORMULA. THANK YOU SENATOR.
AND WHO WOULD TO TAKE THAT FOR.
PH THE P. H. MISTER. ARE YOU
STILL ON THE LINE. THANK YOU.
MY APOLOGIES I LOST CONNECTION
BUT I JUST CAME BACK IN THAT'S
ALRIGHT THANK YOU. DID YOU HEAR
THE QUESTION RELATIVE TO P. P.
HOW ARE WE PREPARING FOR THE
FUTURE AND- CURRENTLY OF COURSE
I GUESS INSURANCE THAT ALL OUR
SNIFFS WILL HAVE SUFFICIENT TV
FOR ALL THE PATIENTS AND STAFF.
THREE THANK YOU DOCTOR PAN AND
MY APOLOGIES FOR MY PHONE- WHO
LOSING CONNECTION THERE FOR A
MOMENT- SO YOU KNOW FOR PPE WE
DO HAVE- WE ASK THAT EVERY
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES
SUBMITTED A MITIGATION PLAN BY
JUNE FIRST. AND ONE OF THE SIX
THINGS THAT EACH FACILITY HAD
TO BE ABLE TO HAS EMERGENCY
PLANS FOR ONE OF THEM WAS FOR
PP. AND THAT THEY WOULD HAVE
CONTRACTS IN PLACE THAT THEY
HAVE STREAMLINED SOME PLACE IN
ADDITION TO THE ABILITY TO
REACH. COMO LACK AND TO THE
STAGE FOR AN EMERGENCY PT. BOB
RIGHT NOW WHAT WE'RE FINDING
OUR SHORTAGES STILL IN GALLONS
AS WELL AS SOME IN NINETY FIVE.
PER GALLON WE HAVE URGED ALL
FACILITIES AND AS THE CDC IF
YOU- BOUGHT COUNTS THE G. WATCH.
THREE YEARS SAFE. I AND NINETY
FIVE WE ALSO SO GUIDANCE ABOUT
OF THE THIS THAT A FOR READ AND
SYSTEM FOR THAT TO DO THAT
SAFELY FOR THEM TO BE READ AND
THEN SEND BACK OUT. BUT WE ARE
WORKING WITH- ENGINEERS THE
WORKING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE ON ADEQUATE PP. EARLY ON
IN THE PANDEMIC WHEN WE SAW
THAT THERE WAS A GLOBAL
SHORTAGE WE PUT IN EARLY-
REQUEST TO THE NATIONAL
STOCKPILE THE STRATEGIC
NATIONAL STOCKPILE. BE ABLE TO
MAKE SURE THAT CALIFORNIA HAD
WHAT THEY NEEDED WE HAPPEN
PRIORITIZING THE P. P. EAT TO
THE SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES.
AND AS IT WAS MENTIONED EARLIER
HOW WE HAVE THAT DASHBOARD THAT
ALLOW US TO SEE AN URGENT NEED
IMMEDIATELY. SO IT'S A- PRETTY
SO IT. NEED OR POPS UP ON THE
SCREEN AS A RIDE FOR THAT DAY
HE CONTACT THEM IMMEDIATELY AND
MANY TIMES IS REQUESTING KEEP
THE EITHER. OR SEEN IN THE-
DAYS THEY MEET OUR OF. I FOR
ECCENTRIC AND SO THEN WE HAVE
THAT EARLY ON. KEEP TO THEN BE
A MAKES THAT WE WITH EITHER
THERE MAY IS THE- AND THE STATE
TO BE ABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY HAVE WHAT THEY NEED GOING
FORWARD I THINK THAT EARLY
INTERVENTION SYSTEM THAT LIFE
DASHBOARD HAS REALLY HELPED US
BE ABLE TO COMMUNICATE BETTER
WITH ALL TWELVE HUNDRED THE
LADIES- WHO ARE USING THAT.
OKAY SO MADE TWO PER CALIFORNIA
TO MISTER ON THAT SO. SHE
YOU'RE DOING A SURVEY- AT I
GUESS MY CONCERN IS THAT WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN SOMEONE COMES BACK
AND SAYS WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
BREAKS SO CAN YOU SPEAK. TO THE
STATE ASSURING THAT THEY HAVE
THAT SUPPLIES SO I HEARD ABOUT
INDIVIDUAL CONTRACTS FRANKLY-
GIVEN HOW SORT THE SUPPLY IS
THE CHALLENGES A GETTING
RELIABLE VENDORS AND SO FORTH
EVEN THE STATE'S HAD SOME
CHALLENGES IN THE STATES VERY
LARGE AND HAS A LOT MORE STAFF.
I JUST WANT TO BE SURE THAT
WE'RE NOT. CLICKING A SURVEY
AND FIND OUT RESULTS THAT ARE
DOWN WE NEED TO BE SURE THEY
HAVE THAT P. T. E. AND WE NEED
TO BE SURE THAT OUR WHOLE STATE
SUPPLY CHAIN. HAS SUFFICIENT PP
FOR OUR NURSING HOMES AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR PRIORITIZING
THEM BECAUSE WE HAVE A
HOSPITALS AND NURSING HOMES AND
NINE INCHES AS WE OPEN UP BY
THE WAY. THERE'S GONNA BE MORE
DEMAND FOR PP FROM NOT JUST
HEALTH FACILITIES BUT ALSO FROM
VARIOUS SITES BECAUSE THEY HAVE
TO PROTECT OUR CUSTOMERS AND
OUR WORKERS AS WELL SO ARE WE
WORKING THAT INTO THE ENTIRE
QUESTION ON HOW MUCH PP WE NEED
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
PERHAPS THE OTHER. BUT ALSO.
AND MAYBE MISS FOR ALSO TO THIS
IS THAT IS THERE AN EFFORT TO
PERHAPS CREATE A STATEWIDE
PURCHASING POOL FOR PP- THROUGH
THE STATE SO THAT SIMPLE PEOPLE
EXCEPT HAVE THE ENDED ON OUR
OWN. CAN BILL AND PERHAPS YOU
KNOW PUT SOME MONEY INTO A POOL
OR SOMETHING SO THAT WE CAN GET
MORE. YOU DELIVERY SUPPORT
POWER THE STATE TRY TO GET TV
EVE. NURSING HOMES AS WELL AS
OTHER PEOPLE WHO NEED. EIGHTY
NO IT'S- QUESTION. THE OF YOU
KNOW PURCHASING. I KNOW THAT
SOMETHING. OF DONE THAT SO
FRANK. LIKE KNOW KAISER. I'M
SOME OF YOUR LAW. ENTITY MAY
LOOK AT YOU KNOW PP TO BE ABLE
TO KIND OF POOL THEIR RESOURCES
TOGETHER AND THEN INTO THE MAKE
THOSE ASK. ON THE WAY THAT THE
STATE EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS
OFFICE WORKS. IS THAT FIRST-
INDIVIDUAL FACILITIES MUST TRY
TO- WORK WITH THEIR EXISTING
SUPPLY CHAINS AS YOU HAD
MENTIONED- AND THEN HOW
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS WORKS IN
OUR STATE IS THAT IT WOULD THEN
GO TO THE COUNTY. WORK THROUGH
THAT. WERE BELIEF IS THAT IT
SHOULD BUBBLE OPERATE THAT
LOCAL AND REGIONALLY. FIRST AND
THEN IT COMES TO THE STATE. OF
AS FAR AS THE STATE UP I DO
KNOW THAT AS OF THIS LAST
WEEKEND WHEN I WAS ASKING ARMS.
THIS OFFICE FAR AS WHAT.
RESOURCES WE WERE SCARE SOMEONE
WE WERE STILL SCARES ON IN
NINETY FIVE. AND NINETY FIVE-
ALL OTHER ITEMS IT SEEMS THAT
WERE ABLE TO FILL MORE OUT. LEE
BUT SEE IT'S YOUR CALL. BUT IF
YOU ARE SURVEY AND WE WERE. IN
THE- WHAT THEY NEED. THREE YOU.
ONLY REGIONAL THEN TO THE STATE.
TO BE ABLE TO DUE TO ADJUDICATE
THOSE. RESOURCES THAT SORT THAT
IN SO WE ALSO TO. THAT TO CLOSE
THAT LOOP TO MAKES THAT YOUR
APPS RIGHT IT'S NOT JUST
SOMEONE SAYING I NEED SOMETHING
AND THEN WE'RE NOT ACTUALLY
THEN. CLOSING THAT WOULD TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT HE WAS A
FIELD IN SOME WAY SHAPE OR
FORM. AND SENATOR PAN I THINK
DOCTOR GUNS AND HEISER HAS HIS
HAND UP AS WELL TO OKAY JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE. HE HAS
ADDITIONAL FOLLOW UP ON THIS
QUESTION. PERHAPS FOR THEN.
THANK YOU YES THANK YOU
SATURDAY AFTER YOUR QUESTION I
REALLY APPRECIATED YOU KNOW AT
A LOCAL LEVEL OF COURSE WE'RE
TRYING TO COORDINATE THE PP
AVAILABILITY NOT JUST TO
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES BUT ALSO
TWO THOUSAND CIVIL UNLICENSED
FACILITIES FOR MAY ALSO BE
NEEDED AND WE SEE THAT IN THE
SHORT TERM THIS REMAINS A VERY
SERIOUS CHALLENGE. OF COURSE
WORK AND IN TERMS OF WERE
PROTECTION TALK ABOUT AND
NINETY FIVES MEDICAL MASS AND
THEN OF COURSE THESE A CLOTH
FACE COVERINGS- AND SO WE'RE
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH OUR
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
AGENCY LOOKING AT ALL THE P. B.
AVAILABLE IN THE COUNTY OUR
SYSTEM TO TRACK WHERE THEY'RE
SHORTAGE IS- AS YOU PROBABLY
KNOW THE CDC CAL OSHA ALLOW FOR
AND THREE YEARS OF ROUGH. IN
SOME OTHER MEN. AND WE WERE.
RORY WHERE WE DOING IT. YOU
WITH WE NORMALLY WOULD TO ATTY
SUPPLY. SO WE DON'T REALLY SEE
A SHORT TERM SOLUTION WE'RE
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
STATE IT'S BEEN EXTREMELY
HELPFUL BUT ON A LOCAL LEVEL.
EVERYBODY'S WORKING HARD TO
FIND ANYWHERE- THAT CAN PROVIDE
THIS PP TO US TO HELP US. IT'S
A VERY COMPLEX AREA WHEN YOU
LOOK UNDER THE HOOD OF THE
DETAILS ABOUT WHAT PEOPLE
PROVIDE. SOMETIMES IT DOESN'T
MEET SPECIFICATIONS SO THERE'S
A LOT OF A LOT OF WORK IN
SUPPORT THAT'S NEEDED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WHAT'S COMING THROUGH
THE SUPPLY CHANNELS. IS
ACTUALLY PROTECTIVE. THE ONLY
OTHER COMMENT I WOULD ADD IS
THAT THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION LAST WEEK REVISED
ITS CONTENTS AROUND THE USE OF
MASS. AS FOR WERE ALL LOOKING
AT THE DAY IF AS WE LOOK AT
THOSE DIRECT GENERALLY
RECOMMENDING AN EXPANSION IN
THE USE OF A MASS THE
RESPIRATORS. BURKE SAMPLE
DIRECT THEY'RE RECOMMENDING
THAT ANYONE OVER THE AGE OF
SIXTY OR HAS A HEALTH.
CONDITION WE CAN'T GUARANTEE
THAT THEY DON'T HAVE CONTACT
WITH SOMEBODY WHO MIGHT HAVE
COME OVER. TO WEAR A MEDICAL
MASK WHERE IS GENERALLY WERE
RECOMMENDING FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
OTHERWISE HEALTHY. TO WEAR FACE
COVERINGS AND THEY'RE ALSO
RECOMMENDING TO DEVELOP
STANDARDS THE MANUFACTURING.
FOR THOSE FACE COVERING SO THE
AS PEOPLE PURCHASE THEM. WE HAD
A SURE HE'D AT THEIR MEETING
SOME LEVEL OF PERFORMANCE IN
TERMS OF SOURCE CONTROL WHICH
IS. AT I WOULD SAY WE'RE
WORKING VERY WITH THE OF GOT A
GOOD JOB AND COUNTY TO MEET THE
SHORT TERM NEEDS OVER WERE WERE
DEVELOPING SYSTEM SO WE HAVE A
REAL TIME INDICATOR OF HOW WELL
WE'RE DOING BUT WE'RE STILL IN
A SHORTAGE THAT YOU CAN THERE'S
AWFUL LOT STATE FEDERAL FREE UP
THE SUPPLY CHAIN WHATEVER
SPEEDED UP TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE UNKNOWNS THAT IS STILL COME
UP IN THE FUTURE SO WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT. THANK
YOU DOCTOR AND SENATOR PAN DID
YOU HAVE ANY OTHER FOLLOW UP
QUESTIONS OR ADDITIONAL.
MEASURES HOPING MISTER
CONNECTED ALSO RIVER OKAY FIND.
MR CLINTON. YES THANK THANK YOU
AND THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
SENATOR PAN OUT I DO DO THINK
THE SUPPLY CHAINS OF CERTAINLY
IMPROVED I WILL SAY TO YOU
THOUGH AND I THINK FACILITIES
FACILITIES ALREADY HAD
CONTRACTS. WHEN WE WENT INTO
THIS BUT MOST OF HAD CONTRACTS
WITH MAJOR SUPPLIERS- BUT THE
SUPPLIERS COULD WOULD PROVIDE
THE D. E. THEY HAD CONTRACTS
WITH MULTIPLE SUPPLIERS AND THE
AND THE PP JUST WEST OF
AVAILABLE HOPEFULLY AGAIN HI
JAMES- COME BACK THAT'S A GOOD
THING BUT IT IT'S JUST NOT
THERE I MEAN PLEASE DONE BEG
BORROW AND STEALING EITHER THEY
CAN FIND IT IT'S JUST NOT THERE
IT'S NOT THERE. FACILITY NO
HAVE EVEN MANUFACTURED SOME OF
THEIR OWN. AS A RESULT TO
THEY'VE HAD BE IS. AS POSSIBLE
ON THIS AND AS YOU HER DOCTOR
TO SAY SO OF THE GUIDANCE
CHANGE HAS CHANGED REGULATE ON
THIS TO IN TERMSOF THE TYPE.
HE HE THAT IS NECESSARY. I
WOULD JUST ADD ONE OTHER THING
TO YOUR INITIAL POINT TO
SENATOR AND- AS YOU SAID ABOUT
OPENING UP. ONE THING THAT IS
VERY IMPORTANT- OR FACILITIES
FACILITIES VERY MUCH WOULD LIKE
TO GET- WE OPENED FAMILY
BUSINESS- WE HAVEN'T INITIATIVE
IN MY ASSOCIATION ON A FAMILY
HOME COMING. VISITATION EFFORT-
LOOKING RIGHT NOW AND WE'RE
GONNA BE MAKING SUGGESTIONS TO
THE STATE ON THAT. BUT THAT'S
GOING TO BE REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT THAT WE HAVE MAKE SURE
THAT THERE IS- THERE'S- PLENTY
OF PP AVAILABLE TO THE EXTENT
MORE VISITORS START COMING
INTO. THE LEASE TO THE
VISITATION VERY IMPORTANT IN
THE CONTACT FAMILIES. BUT WE'VE
GOT TO MAKE SURE. PEOPLE ON THE
OUTSIDE- DOES NOT RESULT IN A
NEW STORAGE WITH THAT ARE
WITHIN OUR FACILITIES. WHEN
GUESTS SENATOR PAN RIGHT AND IT
THANK YOU OF MANAGER I JUST ONE
OTHER QUESTION ACTUALLY PERHAPS
FOR A C. P. H. HIGH I MADE
REFERENCE TO THE FALL I THINK
CONCERNS ABOUT KNOWING
CORONAVIRUS A SLEW OF BOTH
COMPETING FOR HOSPITAL BEDS.
OURS USUAL FLU VACCINATION RATE
IN THE COMMUNITY IN A TYPICAL
FLU SEASON SOMEWHERE AROUND 45%
TO HEALTHY PEOPLE TWENTY TWENTY
GOALS SEVENTY PERCENT- THOSE
HOSPITAL BEDS- THAT WOULD BE
SAVED BY REDUCE INCREASING
ORGANIZATION RATES WOULD BE
VERY USEFUL- TO. IF NECESSARY
TO CARE FOR CORONAVIRUS VICTIM
SO. WHAT IS CITY PH DOING TO
TRY TO INCREASE THE FLU
VACCINATION RATE AND OF COURSE
THIS FLU AFFECTS PEOPLE IN
NURSING HOMES- MORE SIGNIFICANT
AS WELL JUST LIKE RUN A VIRUS.
SO BY INCREASING OUR COMMUNITY
FLU VACCINATION RATE WE CAN
HELP SAVE LIVES IN A NURSING
HOMES AS WELL. SO WHAT ARE WE
DOING TO TRY TO GET OUR FLU
VACCINATION RATE FROM 40% TO
SEVENTY PERCENT. AND ALSO I
GUESS RELATED TO THAT HAVE YOU
HEARD FROM CDC ABOUT EFFORTS
TAX INCREASE THE SUPPLY OF FLU
VACCINE BECAUSE MANUFACTURERS
ONLY. PRODUCING NOW FOR USUAL
45% WE'RE GONNA HAVE SHORTAGE
IS TRYING TO HIT THE SEVENTY
FIRST. AT THAT POINT TIME SO
PERHAPS HE TEACH AND WE CAN
TALK ABOUT WHAT'S THE PLAN TO
GET US TO THAT 70% BACK WE NEED
DIVERSE PEOPLE ONLY FROM FLU
BUT ALL IN FRONT OF MY- AND.
RIGHT I HAD THE EDITOR. THANK
YOU TO PAN I'M I. THE TO
LOOKING AT BECAUSE THAT SIX
WHAT WE'RE DOING AS WELL-
BEFORE WE EVEN HAD SLEAZE
SEASON WHAT'S EVEN MORE
CONCERNING IS WE HAVE TO CRISIS
SEES THAT WE ARE LOOKING TO.
FOR FLU THE FIRST ONE WILL BE
THE PSP **** THE PUBLIC SAFETY-
POWER SHUT OFF. CONCERN WITH
THAT HAPPENING THIS SUMMER IN
ADDITION WHILE WE'RE HANDLING
THE PANDEMIC. UNCRITICALLY FOR
OUR SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES
WHO- FOUR HITS- HARDEST BY
THOSE- PS YESES. THE SECOND ONE
THAT WE ARE PREPARING FOR IS
WILDFIRE SEASON WHICH WILL COME
AFTER THAT MOST LIKELY IN THE
LAST FEW SEASONS IT'S BEEN
HITTING IN LATE SUMMER EARLY
FALL- ON IN THAT MOVIE AT THE
SAME TIME THAT YOU WERE
EXPECTING. A POTENTIAL PEAK-
OVER KOBE CASES- WE DID SET UP
SEVERAL DIFFERENT ALTERNATIVE
CARE SITES AS YOU KNOW BACK IN
THE SPRING WE'VE HAD THOSE
LUCKILY BECAUSE WE WERE ABLE TO
KIND OF BEND THE CURVE WE WERE
ABLE TO NOT HAVE TO USE ALL
THOSE ALTERNATE CARE SITES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. WHAT WE
STAND PREPARED TO HAVE TO USE-
THOSE ALTERNATIVE CARE SITES
THAT WE CREATED ACROSS THE
STATE- IF NEEDED. TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE SAFE EVACUATION OR SAFE
MEDICAL SPACES- IN THE CASE OF
WILDFIRES FOR PS PS OFFENSE
THAT- REQUIRE US TO MAKE SURE
THAT- PATIENTS ARE TRANSFERRED
TO STATE SPACES- THEN. AFTER
YES YES IT IS AND AFTER WHILE
FIRST SEASON THEN COMES THE
FLU-AND PENDING ON WHERE OUR
KIDS. CASES AND THE NINE WELL
PEOPLE ARE ABIDING BY WEARING.
AND DOING STATE PRACTICE WELL
THERE ARE PUBLIC WE BE THAT
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN YOU KNOW I.
DON'T HAVE A CRYSTAL BALL THAT
IT COULD HAPPEN ANY TIME I'M
ANY NON ON PEOPLES DISCIPLINE
DURING THIS PERIOD OF OPENING-
IN SO WITH THE FLU SEASON- I
KNOW THAT WE WILL BE PUSHING
VERY HARD- TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE ARE DOING EVERYTHING TO
PROTECT THEMSELVES. WE ARE
HOPING THAT BECAUSE OF COAL
THEN- AND THE HEIGHTENED
AWARENESS AROUND PUBLIC HEALTH
IN GENERAL- AND ABOUT HAVING
THESE CONVERSATIONS OVER THE
LAST SIX MONTHS ABOUT WHAT
HEARD IMMUNITY IS- TAXI INS AND
ALL. IS FOR NATION THAT HAS
BEEN REALLY TAKING A DIFFERENT
SPENT OVER THE LAST FEW MONTHS
OF REPENT AND MAKE. WE'RE
HOPING THAT THAT WILL NOT ONLY
HEIGHTENED THE EDUCATION AND
AWARENESS LEVEL OF THE
IMPORTANCE OF A FLU SHOT- BUT
WE ARE HOPING THAT WILL ALSO
RESULT IN A MORE PEOPLE- GOING
TO GET THEIR FLU SHOT- AND SO
WILL CONTINUE TO DRIVE- THAT-
THAT EDUCATION OUT. TO THE
PUBLIC. AS FAR AS THE CDC I
APOLOGIZE I DON'T HAVE THE
INFORMATION- REGARDING IF FOR
ANY GOING TO BE ANY VOLUMES OR
AMOUNTS OF THE FLU. VACCINE
FROM SEE IF I CAN DEFINITELY
TAKE THAT QUESTION BACK TO WEAR
SCIENCES BRANCH YOU HAS
CONNECTIONS THE CDC AND GET
BACK TO OFF LINE. THANK YOU I
DO POINT OUT THAT IS CERTAINLY
A EDUCATION CAMPAIGN WOULD BE
VERY IMPORTANT BUT ALSO WE NEED
TO HAVE TO SUPPLY IMAGINE WE
CREATED THE DEMAND AND WE DON'T
HAVE THE SUPPLY THE SAME ISSUE
RANTED. BUT P. E. THIS IS WHAT
WE'VE ALSO RAN INTO A TESTING-
WE'RE GOING TO EDUCATE PEOPLE
WE ALSO NEED HISTORY SUFFICIENT
SUPPLY OF FLU VACCINES IN
PLACE. SO THAT PEOPLE GET IT
WHEN WITH A THEY WANTED TO
INDEED ITSELF. THANKS VERY MUCH
OF DIRTY MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR PAN AND WE'LL
MOVE ON TO SENATOR DODD. THANK
YOU MADAM. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- I APPRECIATE THE STATIC
OR- ADDRESSING THE PS PS THE
WILD PARK THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S REALLY CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT THAT MOVING FORWARD.
APPS I COULD ASK. CRAIG ON THIS
RECORD THAT JUST A BIT THE- IT
IN IN TERMS UP AS THESE P. S.
P. S. HOPEFULLY- WE DON'T HAVE
A LOT OF THOSE THIS YEAR BUT- I
KNOW HOPE IS NOT A STRATEGY WE
HAVE TO PREPARE- WHAT KIND OF
PREPARATIONS TO THESE- THIS
THIS THIS IS THIS INDUSTRY
MAKING TO PROTECT TH MOST POR
EL AMOUNTS AS THAT THAT LIVE IN
THOSE HOMES PARTICULARLY IN
THIS COVERED NINETEEN- ERA
THAT. THAT WERE IN AND
SEGREGATING THOSE PATIENTS IN
KEEPING PEOPLE SAFE. MR CORNET
YES I THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION CENTER DOT- I WOULD I
WOULD TELL YOU THAT I THINK
THAT FACILITIES FACILITIES HAVE
VERY ROBUST- AYE AYE MERCHANTS
THE PLANNED- EIGHT SPECIFICALLY
IN THIS ARENA THEY ARE THEY ALL
DO- WE ARE- NUMEROUS- ONGOING
EDUCATIONAL EFFORTS TO TAP THE
PHILLIES UPDATE THOSE PLANS AND
TO GET ON THAT BEST GUIDANCE
ABOUT WORKING THERE AT WITH
THEIR LOW AGENTS OPERATIONS
SEEK H. R. THAT IS A ROUTINE
ONGOING- THING THEY ALL ALL
FACILITIES ALSO. I HAVE TO
MAINTAIN AB GENERATORS IN CASE
OF A POWER LOSS- AS WELL- SO I
TAKE IT. AS AS YOU WELL AT YOU
A DEADLY NOTE DURING THE RIGHT
THIS PARADISE FIRE THREE
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES THAT
BURNED TO THE GROUND IN
PARADISE AND A NUMBER OF OTHER.
FACILITIES TO ALL NOT A SINGLE
RESIDENT- OUR STAFF PERSON WAS
A- WAS HARD AND THOSE THAT
HORRIFIC- A DISASTER- AND I
THINK IT BOB IS THE LEAVES ARE
ARE ARE YOU KNOW WELL PREPARED-
GOING FORWARD AND I GUESS IT
THIS IS THE PRIORITY OBVIOUSLY-
EVERY KNOWING THAT- THE FIRE
SEASON IS. IS UPON US AND WE'LL
BE RIGHT AWAY. THANK YOU AND
SENATOR DODD DID YOU HAVE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS THANK YOU OKAY.
WE WILL MOVE ON TO SENATOR
WINNER AND THEN SENATOR BATES.
I THANK YOU. VERY MUCH- SO I
THINK ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE'VE- ALL- AGREE LEARN THE
THOUGHT ABOUT IS OF THE- A LOT
OF IT HAS HIGHLIGHTED THE
VULNERABILITY. OF OUR RESIDENTS
IN NURSING HOMES CODE ISN'T THE
ONLY THREAT THERE ARE OTHER
INFECTIOUS DISEASES AND IT'S
REALLY. SHOWN SOME OF THE
VULNERABILITIES WHICH WE CAN OF
COURSE WORK TO IMPROVE WITH
SUMMER FUNDAMENTAL. AND OF
COURSE WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT
PEOPLE ONLY GOING TO NURSING
HOMES IF IT'S ABSOLUTELY.
ESSENTIAL NO WE'RE NOT FORCING
PEOPLE INTO NURSING HOMES AND
WE CAN AVOID IT. WITH SMART
INVESTMENTS- IN THE PROPOSED
BUDGET BY THE ADMINISTRATION
THEIR CUTS TO THE OKAY THEIR
HEALTHCARE. BY TO ASSESS SO FOR
THESE ARE CRITICAL SERVICES.
THAT HELP KEEP. ARE VULNERABLE.
IN THEIR HOMES. INDEPENDENCE OR
AT LEAST MORE INDEPENDENT- AND
I'M NOT CRITICIZING THE
GOVERNOR I DISAGREE AND THE
LEGISLATURE HAS EXPRESSED THAT
THIS AGREEMENT WITH THESE CUTS.
I KNOW THE GOVERNOR OF COURSE
DOES NOT WANT TO BE CUTTING
THESE WERE A TERRIBLE
SITUATION. BUT THESE ARE
CRITICAL CRITICAL SERVICES TO
HELP PEOPLE AVOID GOING INTO
NURSING HOMES- WITH ALL THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE SEEN.
SO IF YOU COULD COMMENT ON JUST
YOUR PERSPECTIVE ON HOW WHAT
KIND OF SMART INVESTMENTS WE
CAN BE MAKING. AND PROTECTING
TO KEEP SENIORS OUT OF NURSING
HOMES IN THE FIRST PLACE. THANK
YOU AND SENATOR WIENER WAS THAT
DIRECTED TOWARD ANYONE
SPECIFICALLY OR WHATEVER OKAY.
THANK YOU N. WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TAKE THAT UP. WE HAVE CRAIG.
OKAY THANK YOU. I'LL START THAT
ONE DOES- STARTED WINNER OF AND
I JUST WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR
THIS PROFESSION- HAS NEVER HAS
ALWAYS BELIEVED AND CONTINUES
TO ADVOCATE THAT- THAT OUR
SENIORS AND THAT SHOULD BE IN
THE MOST APPROPRIATE PLACEMENT
POSSIBLE IF THAT'S IN A IF AT
SOME SKILLED NURSING FACILITY
THAT'S AT HOME WITH MY HSS ARE
SOME OF THE- PERFORMANCE HOME
HEALTH CARE IF THAT'S AN
ASSISTED LIVING THAT IS
WHATEVER IS MOST APPROPRIATE
SETTING IT POSSIBLE. I WOULD
POINT OUT TO YOU THAT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO THE CONVERSATION ON
THIS BECAUSE THE DEPARTMENT
HEALTH CARE SERVICES TWO WEEKS
AGO- OUTLINED A NEW PUZZLE BUT
THEY'RE LOOKING INTO HEIDI
MIGHT COMMENT ON THIS BUT- TO
LOOK AT A LONG TERM CARE AT
HOME BENEFIT- FOR NEXT YEAR
MEDI CAL- BETTER THAT I THINK
IT JUST IN ITS INFANCY SO I YOU
KNOW MY OFFICE MY BACK ALONG
WITH OTHERS HAVE EXPRESSED
CONCERNS ABOUT THAT. THE LACK
THAT SOME OF THE BUDGET. WE
UNDERSTAND. THE DEPTH JOB. AND
IN CRAP A BUDGET THIS. BUT UP.
BUT I JUST WANT TO BE BE CLEAR
THAT THE PROFESSION IS NOT. I
FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT EVERYONE
SHOULD BE IN A SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY BY ANY STRETCH. OF THE
FOLKS WHO COME TO OUR
FACILITIES IF YOU LOOK AT HOW
THEY HELP THE THAT HAS CHANGED
OVER TIME. MORE AND MORE-
PEOPLE ARE STAYINGHOME LONGER.
AND WHEN THEY GET TO SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES THEY TEND TO
BE MUCH OLDER AND MUCH MORE
FRAIL. THAT HAS ALSO BEEN ONE
OF THE REAL PROBLEMS WE FOUND
IN KOBE IT IS BY THE TIME THEY
GET TO OUR FACILITIES THEY ARE
VERY HEALTH COMPROMISED. AND
MUCH OLDER THAN THEY WERE
MAYBE. TEN OR TWENTY YEARS AGO.
SO WE LOOK FOR TO THAT DIALOGUE
AND I WOULD JUST SAY THAT LONG
TERM CARE AT HOME BACK. STATE
IS TALKING. THANK YOU MISTER
QUINN AND I BELIEVE WE HAVE
ANOTHER COMMENT FROM MR CHICKEN
TELL. THANK. YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR- QUESTION SENATOR WIENER-
CANTOR DEFINITELY AND THE WHOLE
OF RESIDENT COMMUNITY- HAS HAS
TAKEN A STRONG OPPOSITION TO
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET
CUTS IT'S AT LEAST ON THE
COMMUNITY SERVICE. YOUR VITAL
TO KEEPING PEOPLE OUT OF
NURSING HOMES WHICH IS EVEN
MORE CRITICAL THAN NORMAL AT
THIS TIME DURING THE PANDEMIC
WERE SO MANY PEOPLE IN
CONGREGATE LIVING SEVEN. OUR
OUR ENTIRE RACE I'M YOU WHAT'S
WHAT WAS REALLY STRIKING TO US
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS
CONTRASTING THE HOME HEARING
BASED SERVICE CUTS. THERE WERE
PROPOSED WITH ALL THE MONEY
THAT WE'VE BEEN GROWING OVER TO
NURSING HOMES DURING THIS
PANDEMIC. THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS. EVER BILLION
DOLLARS NO STRINGS ATTACHED.
THE NURSING HOMES ANOTHER STATE
IS PROPOSING TO DO SIMILAR
STUFF- I'M VERY CONCERNED WITH.
THE SYSTEMREIMBURSEMENT THAT
WE HAVE TO OUR MEDICAL SYSTEM
IS ABOUT THE PRE AUTHORIZED
THIS MONTH BY THE. LEGISLATURE
AB SIXTY TWENTY NINE. WE CAN
STICK YEAR OFTHIS. SYSTEM THAT
HAS HAS GIVEN US A LOT SELF.
BILLION OWNERS WHO COULD BE CAN
BE ANY LESS CONCERNED ABOUT THE
WELFARE OF THE RESIDENTS WE
NEED TO- WE NEED TO TIE THIS
MONEY INTO A SACK MINIMUM
STAFFING LEVELS. AND TO MORE
QUALITY MR CLINTON MENTIONED IN
SOME OF THE SOME OF THE RACES
OR SOME OF THE FUNDING GHOST
SHIP QUALITY CARE MEASURES. BUT
BUT THOSE MEASURES OR SELF
REPORTED BY THE FACILITIES AND
IT'S JUST A SMALL FRACTION IN
THE RESIDENT INPUT IN THIS
QUALITY. IT IS NOT CONSIDERED
AT ALL- SO I THINK IT'S REALLY
TIME TO. TO RETHINK THIS SYSTEM
THAT WE HAVE. TO MAYBE DO A ONE
YEAR CATCH ON THE WAY WE FIND
NURSING HOMES AND TO SPEND THIS
YEAR RECONSIDERING
FUNDAMENTALLY. ALWAYS HOW WE
CONNECT THE MONEY THAT WE'RE
SPENDING THE BETTER QUALITY
BECAUSE THE RESIDENTS TO SERVE
THAT. THANK YOU MISTER CHECK
TELL AND I THINK SENATOR WIENER
IS DONE WITH HIS QUESTIONS WILL
MOVE ON TO SENATOR BATES. THANK
YOU YOU CAN HEAR ME I HOPE YES.
I DO WANT TO CONCUR WITH US
SENATOR JACKSON AND SENATOR-
POUNDS COMMENTS REGARDING OUR
BY HEALTH OFFICERS OF THE
UNFORTUNATE SITUATION WITH
DOCTOR QUICK WAS IN MY COUNTY
AND I WILL SHARE WITH YOU WHILE
I WAS A SPENDING MOST OF MY
TIME IN THE DISTRICT ON SENATOR
AMINO DOCTOR QUICK. ON MONDAY
WEDNESDAY OF EVERY WEEK WAS
PROVIDING THE ORANGE COUNTY
DELEGATION WITH UPDATES ON OUR
PROGRESS TO MEET THE CHALLENGES
OF THIS PANDEMIC SHE DID AN
INCREDIBLE JOB THE ISSUE THE
HOUSE REALLY CIRCULATED AROUND.
THE FACEMASK ISSUE AND NOT TO
DEBATE OUT HERE- THAT SOMETHING
THAT I THINK MORE EDUCATION ON
NEEDS TO BE OUT THERE YEAH WHAT
A GOOD IDEA I FRANKLY I JUMPED
ON THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE ONE
SO I WOULDN'T BE TOUCHED MY
FACE IT WAS GREAT ENTER. BUT
IT'S UNFORTUNATE SHE'S AGREED
ON HEALTH OFFICER AND I'M SURE
A GREAT CAREER STILL WAITS- SO
THANKS TO THAT BUT BUT WE
SHOULD GIVE THEM. SUPPORT CAN
AS A- THEY'RE THERE TO PROTECT
US. I MIGHT MIGHT. IN MY CLASS
ARE SPECIFIC OF. THE SIX
ELEMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN PUT
FORTH BY A CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENTOF PUBLIC HEALTH- TO
ENSURE. THAT WE ARE ACTUALLY-
ADDRESSING THE ISSUES THAT HAVE
OCCURRED IN OUR OFFICE OF. ANY
OF SUB THROUGHOUT THE STATE IN
PARTICULAR I WAS TAKEN BY THE
COMMENTS BY A DOCTOR NEWS AND
HOW OUR- REGARDING AT THE
NUMBER OF- FACILITIES THAT ARE
IN IN HIM LA COUNTY THOSE WHO
HAVE COMPLETED THE PLAN AND
SUBMITTED IT TO THE STATE. AND
OUT OF THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN TO ENTER SEVENTY OF
BEING COMPLETED WHICH LEAVES A
LITTLE OVER FORTY THAT STILL
HAVE NOT. THAT WAS DUE ON JUNE
FIRST PERHAPS BY JUNE TENTH.
AND THAT THE FIRST THREE
ELEMENTS ARE PROBABLY
FUNDAMENTAL TO INSURING- THAT
THE INFECTION RATE IN OUR SNAPS
GOES DOWN AND OUT THE
VULNERABLE WITH MOST FACILITIES
ARE PROTECTED. BUT AS
IMPORTANTLY THE STAFF AND LET
ME SHARE WITH YOU A VERY QUICK
A SITUATION THAT HAPPENED TO A
CONSTITUENT OF MINE A FAMILY
MEMBER WHO IS A STAFFER ON TRNA
A IN A- YOU KNOW WE CAN. AT THE
YOUNG AGE OF FONG IN EARLY
THIRTY. WITH ELEVEN OLD AT HOME
SHE CONTRACTED THAT IN THE
FACILITY AND WAS NOT ALLOWED TO
BE TESTED. NOR WERE THEY
ALLOWED TO WEAR A P. P. E. THAT
WAS AVAILABLE BECAUSE THEY FELT
IT WOULD BE FRIGHTENING. TO
THOSE IN THE FACILITY AND
CERTAINLY VISITORS THAT WERE
STILL ALLOWED AT THAT TIME. SO
THERE'S A TIMING ISSUE HERE AND
I'M CERTAINLY VERY AWARE OF
THAT BECAUSE THIS IS EARLY AND
NOW- THE- PANDEMIC ARE IMPACTS
ON YOU KNOW YOU'RE SEEING HOMES
THE HOT SPOTS WERE NOT
NECESSARILY TO FIND AT THAT
TIME. BUT GOING FORWARD WE'VE
LEARNED AND THAT CERTAINLY THE
GENESIS OF THE SIX ELEMENTS.
BUT TO HAVE FORTY WHO ARE SHORT
AS OF JUNE FIRST IN MEETING
THAT PLAN IS CONCERNING
BECAUSE- THOSE COULD BE THE
VERY FACILITIES WERE A LOT.
COULD HAVE BEEN THE HOT SPOTS
SOME OF THOSE ARE FEATURE. BY
THE WAY ON THE LA MEDIA. OR I'D
LIKE TO ASK DOCTOR. HELGESEN
HAUSER- IF HE COULD RESPOND TO
WHAT WE DO OR WHAT THEY DO WELL
WITH THOSE WHO ARE DELAYED OR
ARTIFICIALLY MEETING ALSO.
BECAUSE I DO BELIEVE A LOT OF
MORE RESOURCES NEED TO GO TO
OUR- OUR- THE STAFF ARE ARE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HERE A
CALIFORNIA. BUT THE ENFORCEMENT
ISSUE OF I WANT XIN THAT I WAS
SO WORKER. ME HERE'S A WHEN
THEY ACCOUNTS MY ASSIGNED WAS
OF NURSING AT THAT TIME A LOT
THEY'VE MADE A LOT A LOT OF
PROGRAMS SCHOOLS WERE VERY DARK
DAYS. BUT WE STILL HAVE THE
PROBLEMS AND UNLESS THERE'S
ENFORCEMENT IN ITS VERY. ARE
STRICT IN SEVERE IF THEY'RE NOT
MEETING THE STANDARDS WE PUT
STAFF. AND WE PUT THOSE
INDIVIDUALS ARE REALLY YOU KNOW
IT IS THE EXTREME DANGER-
INCLUDING LOSING THEIR LIVES
AND CERTAINLY AFFECTING THEIR
FAMILIES. SO I'D LIKE TO CAMP-
THE DOCTOR SHARE WITH US YOU
KNOW THE SERIOUSNESS OF THIS
AND THE PASSION WITH WHICH THEY
ARE REALLY FOLLOWING. UP ON IN
PARTICULAR THE ONE TWO THREE
BECAUSE THAT IS THE ANSWER TO
ENSURING THAT. GOING FORWARD-
THESE INDIVIDUALS AND STAFF
FULL CERTAINLY FEEL MUCH MORE
COMFORTABLE IN DOING THEIR JOB
AND MAYBE WE WON'T HAVE SO MUCH
PROBLEM WITH THE STAFFING ISSUE.
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES- DOCTOR
GOES AND CONSENT HEISER. THANK
YOU SATURDAY TO REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR QUESTION I
THINK YOU'RE RIGHT ON WITH ALL
THE ISSUES THAT YOU MENTIONED.
THE ISSUES OF TESTING HAVE BEEN
EXTRAORDINARY- I CAN SEE
EVERYONE KNOWS THE NATIONAL
CHALLENGES THAT WERE FACED I
BRIEFLY MENTIONED IN MY
COMMENTS. THERE WERE EXTREMELY
EFFORTS MADE BY OUR BOARD. AND
ALSO BY THE MAYOR LA CITY TO
DEVELOP TESTING CAPACITY HERE
IN LA COUNTY- THEY INVESTED A
LOT OF MONEY UP FRONT TO
CONTRACT OR WORK WITH LOCAL
LABORATORIES. SO THAT WE
WEREN'T RELIANCE ON THE
NATIONAL SUPPLIER ON SOME OF
THE NATIONAL LABORATORIES AND
HAD HUGE AROUND. SO IN A
RELATIVELY SHORT PERIOD OF TIME
WE WERE ABLE TO GET OUR TESTING
UP THROUGH THOSE- CAPACITIES
INTO THE THOUSANDS PER DAY.
WHICH WOULD WHICH PUT US AHEAD
OF A LOT OF JURISDICTIONS AND
ONCE WE SAW THAT. MELODY AND WE
UNDERSTOOD THE IMPORTANCE OF
TESTING AS A KEY TOOL AND
ASSURING SAETY AND NURSING
HOMES- WE DISCARDED THE TAP IN
THE BACK. AND THAT WAY WE RAN
INTO A LOT OF OTHER ISSUES OF
LIKE WHO'S GOING TO DO THE
REGISTRATION WHAT STAFF AND DO
IT HOW DO WE MOVE IT. HOW DO WE
GET THE RESULTS BACK AND CENTER
THE JUST THE LOGISTICS. OF
DEPLOYING AVAILABLE TEST INTO
THESE NURSING FACILITIES TO
SOMETHING NEVER DONE BEFORE. I
FEEL LIKE WE REALLY HAVE GOT
GOT THAT DONE WELL. I WILL
POINT OUT THAT THE REQUIREMENTS
SET BY THE STATEFOR THE
BASELINE TESTING IS. JUNE THIRD
THERE WAS A AND I FELT IT WAS
PUT OUT FEW WEEKS AGO THAT SAID
THEY HAVE TO COMPLETE THIS
BASELINE TESTING AND THEN GOING
SURVEILLANCE THERE WASN'T A DAY
BUT LATER THE STATE CLARIFY IT
WAS JUNE THIRTIETH BASED ON THE
ORIGINAL GUIDANCE. A WE SET A
GOAL TO COMPLETE THAT BASELINE
TESTING AND COMPLETE ALL ROUTE
BREAK TESTING. BY JUNE NINETEEN
WHICH IS. A WEEK FROM THIS
FRIDAY. IN TERMS OF THE FORTY
THAT ARE LEFT WE EXPECT TO HAVE
THOSE DONE WITHIN A WEEK WE MAY
ACTUALLY HAVE ALMOST ALL OF
THEM. BY THIS FRIDAY. SO WILL
ACTUALLY MEET OUR- WILL BE A
BETTER THAN OUR JUNE NINETEENTH
DEADLINE WILL CERTAINLY BE
DONE. THE STATE DEADLINE-
HOWEVER YOU KNOW WE'VE HAD
WE'VE BEEN EXTRAORDINARILY I
WOULD SAY SUCCESSFUL AND GET
MEETING THAT I WISH WE COULD
HAVE DONE EARLIER THE
CHALLENGES WERE HAUNTING WE
WORK OUT A SOLUTION. I WOULD
IMAGINE MANY OTHER COUNTY IS A
REALLY CHALLENGE WE DO HAVE
SOME RESOURCES WE'VE-
REASSIGNED STAFF AS WE CAN.
WE'VE GOT. YOU KNOW TEAMS THAT
GO OUT TODAY I'VE GOT OVER
EIGHT. FACILITIES THAT WERE
CASTING AND WE'RE HAVING STAFF.
IT'S A VERY I LIVE A RESOURCE
INTENSIVE PROCESS TO GET THAT
DONE I IMAGINE A LOT OF
JURISDICTIONS DON'T HAVE THAT
AVAILABLE. SO IT WOULD BE GOOD
TO START TO LOOK AT HOW A
SUPPORT CAN BE PROVIDED- TO
MEET THAT NEED. AND I AND I SO
I COMMENTED IT HAS. BEEN
NOTICEABLE AT THE NUMBER OF
DEATHS HAVE GONE DOWN I DO
THINK THAT THE THREE MAIN
THINGS THAT MADE THE
DIFFERENCE. SOURCE CONTROL THAT
EVERYBODY IN THE FACILITY THE
MORNING A MASK OR RESPIRATOR.
SECOND OF ALL THE TESTING.
INFORM WHO NEEDS TO BE COLD
HEARTED SO WE'VE GOT THE
INFECTED PEOPLE HERE THE- THE
EXPOSED HERE. AND PEOPLE THAT
HAVE BEEN EITHER INFECTED OR
EXPOSED SOMEWHERE ELSE NEW
PEOPLE SHOULD GO INTO A
QUARANTINE UNTIL WE'RE SURE
THAT THEY ALL OF THOSE RISKS.
AND THEN- THE THIRD ELEMENT IS
UP. IS THAT ISOLATION
QUARANTINE BUT IF WE DO THOSE
WELL. THE EVIDENCE SHOWS THAT
THAT THE CASES ARE REALLY
DROPPING EXTRAORDINARILY. THE
ISSUE OF WORKER. LIKE YOU SAID
USING. IMPORTANT WE'VE WE'VE
WITH. TOP PEOPLE WORK THE
FISCAL. AND THEY WANT TO BE
WELL EDUCATED THEY WANT
UNDERSTAND WE HAVE A SYSTEM IN
PLACE IS GOING TO PROTECT THEM
THE PEOPLE THERE CARING FOR.
AND THAT THEY'VE GOT THE
ADEQUATE RESOURCES PARTICULARLY
THE BP. TO SAFEGUARD THEMSELVES
I FEEL WE ARE QUICKLY MOVING IN
THE DIRECTION OF THAT ONE TWO
AND THREE THAT YOU MENTIONED
WHICH I DO THINK FOR THE
CRITICAL STEPS. AND I WILL
HOPEFULLY BE IN A MUCH BETTER
PLACE- DOCTOR CODY MENTION THAT
AND- SANTA CLARA COUNTY THEY'VE
REALLY SEEN A MARKED DECREASE.
HOPEFULLY OTHER COUNTY FROM
MOVING TO THAT PLACE SOON AS
WELL AND WILL CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE THAT PROTECTION GOING
FORWARD. THANK YOU DOCTOR AND
SENATOR BATES I THINK- WE HAVE
DEPUTY DIRECTORS. WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO FOLLOW UP WITH THAT IF.
HI THANK YOU SENATOR BATES FOR
YOUR COMMENTS AND- I AM SO
SORRY THAT WAS YOUR EXPERIENCE
OF YOUR FAMILY MEMBER BUT IT IS
AN EXPERIENCE THAT I HAVE HEARD
TIME AND TIME AGAIN EARLY ON IN
THE CAN DOWN MAKE IN THAT. IN
THAT IS THE CASE OF YEAR. NOT
ONLY FEAR IAN ARE HEALTH CARE
WORKERS- WHO WE DID- ESTABLISH
SOME FREE HOTEL ROOMS FOR
HEALTH CARE WORKERS ACROSS THE
STATE. THAT THEY CAN
DECONTAMINATE THE COULD HAVE A
PLACE TO STAY PARTICULARLY IF
THEY HAVE FAMILY MEMBERS ARE
HOME LIKE IN YOUR CASE ELEVEN
MONTHS STATE THAT THEY WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT- TRYING TO
CREATE AS MANY WRAPAROUND
SERVICES. CAN ALLEVIATE THOSE
FEARS THIS IS MUCH AS POSSIBLE-
BUT THE FEAR ISRAEL BOTH FOR
EITHER THE HEALTH CARE WORKERS
AS WELL AS OUR EVALUATORS GOING
INTO FACILITIES- AND I THINK
THAT. THE KINGDOM BECAUSE GO ON
LINE AND PEOPLE STILL MORE AND
WE HAVE MORE PP. OR. SENATE AND
THAT IS A POWER. TO HOLD STILL
HERE FOR DURING THIS. I DO WANT
TO. AND LA. IN THE COMMENTS
ABOUT THE ALSO THE MITIGATE
PLANS THE MITIGATION PLANS WERE
TO JUNE FIRST. WE HAD A FEW
STRAGGLERS BUT AS OF LAST
WEEKEND- WE HAD A 100% OF OUR
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES TO
SUBMIT THEIR MEDICATION PLANS.
OUR TEAMS ARE NOW REVIEWING
THOSE AND GOING ON SITE. THEY
WILL BE GOING ON SITE EVERY SIX
TO EIGHT WEEKS- TO REVIEW AND
IT'S HAS TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
SAUDIS ARE FOLLOWING UP. WITH
WHAT THEY STATED THAT THEY WERE
ABLE TO DO IN THEIR MEDICATION
PLANS. IN THE CREE WITH
EVERYONE WHO WAS SPOKEN TODAY
REGARDING TESTING. TESTING IS
REALLY REALLY THE KEY FOR US TO
BE ABLE TO OPEN UP THE FLEA.
AND GET WHATEVER NEW NORMAL IN
OUR SOCIETY WE MAY HAVE. AND
WOOD TESTING PARTICULARLY WITH
WITH SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES%
WE RECENTLY LAST WEEK AND THIS
WEEK. HAVING CREATING COUNTY
TESTING MEDICATION PLANS. ARE
COUNTY SPECIFIC INFORMATION
ABOUT THE SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES AND THEY'LL HAVE
OPTIONS WE DO HAVE A LINK OR-
PHP. WEBSITE THAT HAVE THIS ALL
THE POTENTIAL LABS IN THE
STATE- I'M COUNTY STATE.
PRIVATE LAPSED ACADEMIC CALL
LITTLE RESEARCH LABS. I TO
THAT'S- WHAT TESTING CAN DO
THEIR AS WELL AS WHAT TYPES OF.
YEAH SERVICE ALL EVEN DO MOLD
LABS OR SOMETHING HAVE DRY
THROUGH TOWN SOME LABS LACK DO
IS AND WHERE THEY WATCH COME
SPECIMENS BRING THEM TO THE LAB
AND WE PROVIDE ALL THAT IN OR A
LINK AND THAT'S PART OF OUR A
THAT WE SENT OUT TO THE PEOPLE
WHO CAN TO HAVE THAT
INFORMATION AND EDUCATION. NOT
JUST. HOW CAN I TEST IN NEWS
MEDIA LAB THAT SEEMS VERY FAR
AWAY BUT THERE TURN AROUND TIME
MAYBE FASTER THAN WHAT IS THE
CLOSEST LEFT TO ME AND SO
TRYING TO GET PEOPLE TO THINK-
USING LOOKING AT THAT WHOLE
LIST OF WITH THE TURNAROUND
TIMES ARE CLASSICS THAT TRUCK
AS IT THEY CAN HAVE THE
INFORMATION AND BE ABLE TO
CHOOSE WHAT MIGHT WORK THE BEST
FOR THEM BECAUSE WE DO HAVE THE
TESTING CAPACITY IN OUR STATE
NOW. IT'S JUST A MATTER OF SURE
THAT THAT INFORMATION IS OUT
THERE SO THAT PEOPLE FEEL
COMFORTABLE MAKING DECISIONS ON
WHICH WAY WHICH PASSWORD WOULD
BE THE BEST FOR THEIR FACILITY
TO BE ABLE TO TEST. THANK YOU
SENATOR BATES. WHEN ART ONE
LAST QUESTION FOR OUR DAILY
COUNTY I IN TERMS OF-
REPORTING- PROCEDURE IF THERE
ARE I WOULD SAY- DEFICIENCIES-
IS THERE A- EFFICIENT AND
CONFIDENTIAL WHISTLEBLOWER
SYSTEM OF THAT YOU HAVE
AVAILABLE FOR THOSE IN NURSING
HOMES THAT FEEL THERE'S SOME
SIGNIFICANT DEFICIENCIES
PUTTING PUBLIC- THE HEALTH OF
THE STAFF FOUND OF THE MEMBER
THE OF PATIENTS AT RISK-
SOMETHING I THINK HAS BEEN
INSTITUTED. FOR OTHER ISSUES-
IN THE WORKPLACE BUT I THINK
SOMETHING WHERE THERE'S A
CONFIDENTIAL OPPORTUNITY TO
REPORT SO THAT THE MEDIA AT
OVERSIGHT AND ENFORCEMENT IF
NEEDED- COULD COME ONLINE. I
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES AGAIN
FOR THAT QUESTION. I AM AWARE
OF THAT OUR HEALTH FACILITIES
DOES HAVE A PROCEDURE WHERE
THEY CAN- ACTUALLY RECEIVED
COMPLAINTS DIRECTLY- FOR
WORKERS- AND THEY COULD
INVESTIGATE DOES IS NEEDED. I'M
NOT SURE THAT THEY COMPLETELY
COMPLIES WITH SOME OF YOUR
CONCERNS SO FOLKS OKAY WITH YOU
ALL A LTTLE MORE INFORMATION
AND PROVIDE THAT BACK TO YOU
EXACTLY WHAT THE DETAILS ARE OF
THE SYSTEM HERE IN LA COUNTY.
THANK YOU FOR THAT THAT IS ALL
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES WILL
MOVE ON TO SENATOR CABALLERO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MADAM
CHAIR FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ASK A FEW QUESTIONS- FIRST OF
ALL AS I WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY. HERE THAT HERE TODAY
THAT PRESENTED- APPRECIATE YOUR
HARD WORK AND THE OUTSTANDING
COORDINATION THAT THIS CORONA
VIRUS HAS. FIRST ASSAULT TO
UNDERGO. ON BECAUSE THE STATE
TOOK IMMEDIATE ACTION LIVES
WERE SAVED AND I WANT TO SAY
THAT BECAUSE SOME OF THE- SOME
OF THE QUESTION SEEMS AS IF
THEIR CRITICISM. BUT I REALLY
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE WORK
THAT'S BEEN DONE DURING THIS
PERIOD OF TIME DURING A VERY
SHORT PERIOD OF TIME. AND KNOW
THAT I THINK THAT WE ARE GOING
TO HAVE SOME VERY VERY
IMPORTANT LESSONS LEARNED THAT
WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO TAKE
INTO THE FUTURE. SO HOPEFULLY
WE'RE KEEPING TRACK OF THOSE-
ONE OF THEM WHICH REALLY HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH THIS HEARING
EXCEPT FOR THAT I'VE BEEN
HEARING FROM MY CONSTITUENTS
OVER AND OVER AGAIN ABOUT THE
LACK OF TESTING AND THE LACK OF
PP. I REPRESENT A RURAL
DISTRICT BOB GRAHAM FROM THE
CENTRAL VALLEY OVER TO THE
SALINAS VALLEY. AND PEOPLE ARE
SCARED AND I THINK THAT'S BEEN
ACKNOWLEDGED BY THE WORK ARE.
AND I THINK WE. TROLL ARE OWN
FUTURE WHICH IS TO FIGURE A
WEEK PRODUCE OUR OWN P. HERE
THE STATE WOULD BE GREAT A BUT
SUCH FOR THE CONVERSATION
THERE'S TWO ISSUES THAT. THAT I
WANT TO ASK ABOUT AND I THINK
IT MAY HAVE BEEN OUT ANSWERED
SO I'LL I'LL I'LL DO REAL QUICK
AND- REALLY WITH THE PUBLIC.
WANTS TO KNOW IS FAR THEIR
LOVED ONE SAFE. AND SO THE MORE
TRANSPARENCY AND THE MORE THAT
WE CAN BE CLEAR ABOUT WHAT
WE'RE DOING TO KEEP THEIR- THE
MEMBER OF THE FAMILY THAT HE
IS. IN THE FACILITY SAFE I
THINK THAT'S GOING TO THAT'S
GOING TO BE REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT. AND BY THE SAME
TOKEN- I UNDERSTAND THE NEED TO
ISOLATE AND AT TO RESTRICT WHO
GOES INTO THE FACILITIES. BUT
IT- IT IT'S BACK I GUESS THE
QUESTION IS- UNDER WHAT SOME
CIRCUMSTANCES WOULD IT BE SAFE
TO ALTER THAT PARTICULAR
RESTRICTION TO ALLOW. ON A
FAMILY MEMBER TO VISIT. USING
GOOD SCIENCE- BECAUSE WHAT WE
KNOW IS THAT MANY OF THE-
RESIDENTS ARE FRAGILE. AND THEY
DEPEND ON FAMILY MEMBERS TO
COME IN AND MAKE THEIR DAY. OUT
MUCH MORE MANAGEABLE AND THE
STAFF DOES TOO AND SO I'M
WONDERING IF THERE IF SOME
THOUGHT BEEN GIVEN TO. WHAT
KIND OF CHANGES MIGHT MY HELP.
THAT STEM BECAUSE WE HEARD SUCH
A XIN WERE. HAVING MEMBERS WELL
I CAN TELL YOU. THAT THE
SENIORS THAT I KNOW ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT AND HAVE BEEN
SO. WHERE NO CAN VISIT. AND
SEPARATED THE FAN. THANK YOU
AND I HAD QUESTION AS WELL I
MISTER SALAD MENTIONED THE
RESIDENT BEING MORE EMPOWERED
IN THIS PROCESS SO- I DON'T
KNOW IF THAT WAS DIRECTED
TOWARDS ANYONE SENATOR COMING
IT'LL BUT- ACTUALLY RESEARCHER
TELLS RAISING HIS HAND. AREAS
AND THEN CREEK WHEN IT IS NEXT.
FOR YOUR QUESTIONS I'M VERY
GOOD ONES ARE REALLY GOOD ABOUT
A VISITATION BUT LET ME GET
WHAT THE BIG QUESTION ARE ARE
ARE ARE WE'RE LOOKING SAFE. I'M
THERE'S NO WAY TO ANSWER THAT
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO LOOK AT EACH
FACILITY AND I GUESS THE
UNCERTAINTY THAT IS SORT OF THE
ANSWER QUESTIONS. WE CAN'T WE
DON'T KNOW WE CAN'T GUARANTEE
IT. AND I THINK EVEN PRIOR TO
COPE WITH NINETEEN. THAT
QUESTION WITH THE ANSWER
QUESTIONS ON CERTAIN WHICH
SHOULD BE ALARMING TO US. WE
HAVE A RECENT G. A. L. FEDERAL
GAO STATUS SENATE ONE THIRD OF
RESIDENTS IN NURSING HOME
SUFFERS HARM. WITHIN A FEW
WEEKS OF THEIR STAY. SO THESE
ARE FREE DANGEROUS PLACES
ARTICLE THE NINETEEN. I KNOW
THAT THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
EFFORTS AND TO MAKE THEM SAFER
AND I THINK THAT A LOT OF THOSE
EFFORTS HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL.
BUT THERE'S STILL A LOT OF
UNANSWERED. WITH HER TO
VISITATION. THIS WAS ONE OF THE
FIRST CASUALTIES OF THE
PANDEMIC WAS WAS VISITORS AND
IT'S BEEN HEARTBREAKING AND I
DON'T EVEN KNOW IF THERE'S A
REAL RATE PUBLICHEALTH
JUSTIFICATION FOR THE EXCLUSION
OF VISITORS BECAUSE THIS- SO
MANY VISITORS PROVIDED DIRECT
CARE SUPPLEMENTED THE CARE THAT
IS PROVIDED BY SEVENTY SENSUAL
CARE TURNING RESIDENTS MAKING
SURE THAT. MAKING SURE THEY
WERE BAD I'VE HEARD FROM SO
MANY FAMILY MEMBERS WHO WHO HAD
ENTERED THE TIMES IT CAREFULLY
EITHER LOCAL ONE AND THEIR NOT
SO SURE THIS THAT HAVE AT THAT
TIME IN COMPARISON. DO THAT
WITH A LOT OF RESIDENTS RIGHT
SUFFERING FROM LIKE ON DO
NEGLECT THERE ARE DEFINITELY
SUFFERING FROM BEHIND YOU
ISOLATION A LOT OF STATES AND
OTHER COUNTRIES YOU HAVE
STARTED TO OPEN UP ON THIS NO
I'M ASKING YOU JUST LET. CAN
YOU. ARE VISITORS TO DO JOHN
THIS THING MEASURES THIS. WE
PROPOSE THE- INCOME. BUT
CLEARLY THIS. OPENING UP
VISITATION SOME. LIMITED
RESEARCH. BUT FINALLY. HAS NOT
BEEN A PRIORITY I THINK IT'S
HIGH TIME THAT WE COME A- THANK
YOU AND NEXT WE HAVE MISTER
CORNET. YES THANK YOU- I WOULD
POINT OUT THAT AND THEIR
COPYRIGHT I. IMPORTANT VERY
IMPORTANT QUESTION- I WOULD
POINT OUT THAT THAT THE
SURVEYORS THE FOLKS FROM C. T.
H. AND THE PART AND THE LA
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT THEY
HAVE BEEN VISITING FACILITY.
THEY HAVE BEEN DOING THAT
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE THE APP
IS TIRED TIME- THE ISSUE OF
VISITATION AND PARTICULARLY
FAMILY VISITING THERE'S A
NATURAL TENSION HERE I THINK-
AT IN TERMS OF- I'VE HAD TO
MAKE THIS WORKABLE I WILL TAKE
YOU THERE HAVE BEEN MANY
CREATIVE THINGS THAT ALREADY.
OF THOSE FACILITIES HAVE BEEN
USED UTILIZING FACE TIME- OR OR
ARE. THEY JUST TYPING- SO
THEY'RE THEY'RE WITH THEIR
LOVED ONES- AND VERY MUCH ****
AND COMMUNICATE. ALSO JUST. SAM
THAT PRESENTS A OUR OUR CHAO
TO. YOU A YUBA AND I PAY OR A
LOT FROM ROOM TO ROOM IT HAS TO
BE JUST EVERY TIME- EVERY TIME
WITH WILL JUST TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU'RE NOT- POTENTIALLY-
INFECTING SOMEONE OF RIGHT NOW
THOUGH THERE ARE OTHER
FACILITIES HAVE BEEN DOING-
OUTDOOR- SETTING UP OUTDOOR
VISITATION- AND IN IN IN
SOMETIMES EVEN IN PARKING LOTS
OR EVEN ARE IN THAT IN IN THE
OUTDOOR AREAS OF THE TO STILL
BE I THINK YOU WILL SEE MORE
AND MORE AT THAT- THE- AT THIS
POINT I THINK YOU KNOW WE'RE
GONNA BE SUGGESTING. YOU KNOW
SOME DEPENDING ON THE STATUS OF
THE FACILITY AND THE OUT BREAK
ISSUES POTENTIALLYSOME
ADDITIONAL VISITATION FROM
FAMILY MEMBERS WITH WITH
APPROPRIATE THAT DISTANCING-
AND- AND YOU KNOW REQUIRE
EXTENDED USE OF P. P. SO HE'D
BE AVAILABLE- OF THE AD MASKING
AND THEN OUTING AS A FOURTH WAR
UP FOR A VISITORS AS WELL I
THINK WE'RE RIGHT IN THIS RIGHT
NOW I KNOW CITY. LOOK THIS IS.
KING HELLO INSTALLATION FOR
SENIORS DAHLE CROSS WELL BE
STILL NAY FOR BIGELOW AT ENTER
OF ICE THE OF THAT SENIORS WHO
HAVE BEEN IN THAT HOME ON HOLD.
OR A AND I EACH YES AS WELL AND
YOU NEED CERTAINLY IS A I WHEN
OFFICE RIGHT NOW. THANK YOU
MISTER CORNET AND WE'LL MOVE ON
TO- DEPUTY DIRECTOR STRANICA
WHO ALSO HAS INPUT HERE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH EVERYONE FOR
BRINGING UP- THE VERY HARD AND
DIFFICULT- DISCUSSION AROUND
VISITATION AS WE ALL KNOW I
KNOW BOTH PERSONALLY AND
PROFESSIONALLY- THE REALITIES
OF THIS SINCE I TO HAVE LOST
ONE OF MY LOVED ONES. IN A
CONGREGATE SETTING TO KOBE THIS
YEAR- AND- UNDER THE THAT
UNABLE TO VISIT- POLICIES. AT
CMS DID JUST RECENTLY SENT OUT
A MEMO THAT- TWENTY DASH THIRTY
TWO ALL OF THEIR FACILITIES AND
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE. THAT
MOST OF OUR SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES IN CALIFORNIA ARE
CMS FIGHTS BEFORE. AND IN THAT
IT OUTLINES SOME SAY CRACK
BECAUSE WE ARE SEEING. IS THAT
WHERE YOU CAN YOU FOR WHERE YOU
HAVE AN UP TAKING CASES WHO
ALSO TIME THE OBVIOUSLY THEN
HOUSE MORE CASES. IN THOSE
FACILITIES FROM A SYMPTOMATIC
SPREAD WHETHER THAT BE A HEALTH
CARE WORKER MAYBE THAT WOULD BE
A FUTURE VISITOR ON AND SO- I
AGREE- WITH MANY OF THE THINGS
THAT. TONY CHECK A TOPLESS
SHARED WITH ME WE'VE KIND OF
HAD MANY DISCUSSIONS AROUND
THIS AND I THINK MORE TO HOW WE
CREATIVELY. AT THIS AND I KNOW
THAT THERE ARE MANY FACILITIES-
IF THEY DO NOT HAVE AN OUTBREAK
IF THEY HAVE METAL THE TESTING
GUIDELINES OF PP. AND ALL OF
THE GUIDELINES LISTED IN C. M.
S.'S MEMO THEY ARE ABLE TO THEN
RE OPENS FOR AND VISITATION IF
THEY COME. FOLLOW ALL OF THOSE
REQUIREMENTS- AND SO I THINK
ASK ME SEE THAT MOST OF OUR
AFTER JUNE THIRTIETH ONCE ALL
OF OUR FACILITIES AND OTHER
BASELINE TESTING- DEPENDING ON
WHAT THE COMMUNITY SPREAD AND
IF THERE'S AN OUTBREAK VERSUS
NOT AN OUTBREAK IN THEIR AREA-
I. SEE PROBABLY MORE OF WHAT
CRAIG- CORNET WAS DESCRIBING AS
CREATIVE WAYS- THAT PEOPLE ARE
TRYING TO HAVE FUN STATE.
VISITATION WHETHER THAT BE
THROUGH TESTING- WHETHER THAT
BE THROUGH PHYSICAL DISTANCE
SCENE IT'S IMPORTANT TO I KNOW
A LOT OF STATESHAVE LOOKED AT
NO OUT. OUT WERE SITTING. BUT
IT'S IMPORTANT NOTE THAT OF OUR
SOME OF OUR- RESIDENTS NEED
DISABILITY ARE ABLE TO GO
OUTSIDE FOR THEY DON'T- HAVE-
YOU KNOW THE ABILITY TO BE
MOVED IN IN SUCH A WAY- IN SO I
THINK WE NEED TO KIND OF THINK
CREATIVE LINE NOT AROUND.
EQUITY AS FAR AS MAKING SURE
THAT- THAT ALL AS ARE
DISABILITIES YOU KNOW OR- ARE
KIND OF LOOKING AT THOSE THOSE
WAYS. BECAUSE EVEN SOME OF OUR
MORE URBAN SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES MIGHT NOT EVEN HAVE-
YOU KNOW SAFE PROPRIA
OUTSOURCED BASIS EITHER- SO
JUST TRYING TO THINK OF ALL OF
THOSE DIFFERENT COLOR. CITIES
AS WE TRY TO. MAKE SURE. OUR
STATE. AGAIN I KNOW THAT MANY
OF THEM ARE FOR IN THIS
GUIDELINES THE DIFFERENCE FORTH
FAR I. THINK SENATOR KIRBY. DO
YOU HAVE ANY OTHER. NO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ABOUT A I THINK I
WOULD HAVE ANY OTHER. FROM
SENATORS I DO HAVE ONE LAST
QUESTION I MUST ASK IN THAT IS-
AND WE'VE HEARD THIS BEFORE BUT
I KNOW. BOTH AND WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT TESTING STRATEGY
ESPECIALLY FOCUSING ON AREAS
LIKE RULE COMMUNITIES AND-
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. BUT I'M
JUST INTERESTED IN KNOWING HOW
WE'RE CALLING ADDITIONAL
ATTENTION TO PRIORITIZE THESE
COMMUNITIES- ESPECIALLY THE
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES AND
THE TEST STRATEGY THAT WE'VE-
PUT FORWARD AND ENSURING THAT
THESE COMMUNITY- POOR
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED
WITH HIGHER RATES- I KNOW THAT.
CERTAINLY FROM REPRESENTING LA
COUNTY BUT ALL OVER THE STATE
WE'RE SEEING THIS HOW ARE WE
CALLING MORE ATTENTION IS
COMMITTEES. IN THE WAY WE ARE
UP PROCEED FORWARD NOW. YES
WILL START WITH A DOCTOR
CONSENT HIKES HELTER. I THANK
YOU CENTER REALLY GREAT
QUESTION INEQUITIES THAT WE'VE
OBSERVED AROUND OF IT NINETEEN
INTERACTION REALLY
EXTRAORDINARY AS YOU
HIGHLIGHTED THERE'S A COUPLE OF
THEIR SEVERAL THINGS WERE
DOING- IN LA COUNTY WELL
DEPARTMENT I'M IN PUBLIC HEALTH
IS FOCUSED ON THE OUTBREAKS AND
CONTROL OF THE INFECTION. OUR
SISTER DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
SERVICES IS OUR LEADER AND
INDEED THANK TAP INTO THE
COMMUNITY AND THIS ISSUE OF
MAKING TESTING AVAILABLE SO
THAT WE CAN CONTROL THE SPREAD
OF DISEASE AND COMMUNITY SOME
PROTECT INDIVIDUALS WHO MIGHT
BE IN CONCRETE OR OTHER
FACILITIES HAS BEEN A HIGH
PRIORITY. I KNOW YESTERDAY I
WAS TALKING WITH THEIR LEAD
PHYSICIAN AGAIN LOOKING HOW WE
MIGHT HELP OR OTHER COMMUNITY
PARTNERS MIGHT HELP TO EXPAND
TESTING INTO THE STOP THESE
COMMUNITIES THERE'S A NUMBER OF
CHALLENGES THAT WE REALLY HAVE
TO FACE IT'S NOT JUST AS YOU
KNOW MAKING THE FACILITY
AVAILABLE FOR THE TESTING BUT
THERE'S ALSO BUILDING COMMUNITY
TRUST. THERE'S ALSO A LOT OF
EDUCATION- MEDIA INFORMATION
EXPROPRIATE BOTH LINGUISTICALLY
AND CULTURALLY THE COMMUNITY
SERVER ARE GETTING SO WE SEE
THAT THERE'S A STRONG NEED TO
INVOLVE OUR LEADERS IN THESE
COMMUNITY AND. THIS IS OR GOING
TO STATIONS IN I AND NAY NEEDS
ADDITIONAL. THAT WE CAN HELP
THEM. TO HELP US INTO THE
SCREEN ACCURATE AND- THE PEOPLE
DO WONDERS. THE ELEMENTS OF
THIS DISEASE THEY KNOW HOW TO
TEST- THEY KNOW HOW TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES THEY ALSO KNOW WHAT
TESTING IS AVAILABLE TO THEM.
SO WE HAVE A VERY STRONGLY
DEVELOPING STRATEGY TO DE
STRESS THAT YOU'RE IN LA
COUNTY. AND AS THAT COMES INTO
PLAY WOULD BE GLAD TO SHARE
MORE INFORMATION ON THAT WITH
YOU THANK YOU AND I APPRECIATE
THAT I KNOW YOU ALL ARE DOING A
VERY. GOOD JOB IN LA COUNTY IN
ANYWAY WE CAN REPLICATE THAT HE
ON THE- LA COUNTY WOULD BE-
BENEFICIAL FOR US ALL AND- I
THINK YOU FOR THAT DOCTOR NEXT
WE'LL MOVE ON TO DEPUTY
DIRECTOR SIGN OCCUR FOR
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS. YEAH I DO
WANT TO ECHO IN IN THANK YOU
DOCTOR GRANT OUR- HIS COMMENTS
NOT ONLY ABOUT EQUITY IN THE
IMPORTANCE. TO REDUCE FEAR OF
PROVIDE EDUCATION I'M AROUND
TESTING- BUT I ALSO WANT TO
RECOGNIZE AND AS THEY BELIEVE
IT WAS SENATOR BRIO FROM
CENTRAL VALLEY- HAD COMMENTED
THAT. IN OUR WORLD COUNTY AS WE
ARE NOTICING THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE THE SAME. RESOURCES OR
EVEN THE STAFFING LEVELS. AT
THOSE LOCAL PUBLIC COUNTY
HEALTH AND SO WE ARE WORKING
AND PARTNERSHIP WITH THEM. I'M
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
REACHING OUT TO ALL THE SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES GIVING THEM
THE EDUCATION IN SCHOOLS THEY
HAVE. GIVEN HIM THE RESOURCES
LETTING THEM KNOW HOW THEY CAN
TEST WHERE THEY CAN TEST OF
PROVIDING THAT INFORMATION.
THIS IS KIND OF MORE TO- YOU
KNOW RATHER THAN BEING REACTIVE
THAN BEING PROACTIVE AND- AND
MAKING SURE THAT WERE
CONTACTING THEM EVEN THOUGH
WE'RE LICENSURE AND
CERTIFICATION. WE HAVE A WALL
HERE TO PLAY- INTO ASSIST THESE
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICES- I
AM FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY. AND
I KNOW FROM MANY CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH-
THEIR- REALITIES UP. REALLY
CAME STRETCH THEN. TO BE ABLE
TO EVEN- BY STATE. BY THE- TAKE
THIS IS A- LEVEL. GIVING PEOPLE
OPTION BEYOND REGION FOR TEN.
THE WE DO HAVE CAPACITY IN THE
STATE IT'S A OF MAY SURE THAT
THE- ONLY. AND MAKE THOSE
CONNECTION SERVE THE- TO WHERE
THERE IS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I THINK HAT IS IT OUR ON
OUR END FOR ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS- NOW WE
WILL MOVE ON TO PUBLIC COMMENTS
FIRST WILL START AND ASK IF
THERE IS PUBLIC COMMENT. IN THE
GALAXY. THE NONE. WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY. ARE
THERE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY WHO'D- LIKE
TO PROVIDE COMMENTS. THERE ARE
NONE A NEXT WE WILL MOVE TO
PUBLIC COMMENT VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE GIVE
ME THE TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WAITING TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY. I
CURRENTLYHAVE TWO IN Q. IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE A COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. GREAT. THANK YOU
MODERATE ABOUT ADOPTING Q. NOW
OKAY. WE'LL HEAR FROM THE FIRST
PERSON. THANK YOU I NINETEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
LINDA A WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY THE ISSUE IN A
TO SHARE TODAY HIGHLIGHT THE
NEED FOR INCREASED TESTING AT
SCHOOL NURSING FACILITY RIGHT
AND WORKERS AND INVESTING
PROGRAM TO KEEP PEOPLE OUT OF
NURSING FACILITY. POINT CREATE
ALLEGED. BUDGET LAST WEEK
PROTECTS. PROGRAM THAT KEEP
YEARS WE THE CAN YOU. INCLUDING
THE RICH. IN YOUR- CUT.
REJECTING I JUST GOT THE AND
THE P. AND OTHER MEDI CAL
BENEFITS CUTS. AND REJECTION OF
A STATE OR YOU COULD TAKE A LOT
MORE CAL. AND SUPPORT A FINAL
BUDGET INCLUDES PROTECTION THE-
YOUR FACE CLEAN THEIR HOME
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR MUCH
NEXT. A PERSON PLAY. THANK YOU
ARE THIRTY THREE WELL I HAVE.
MY NAME IS GUN CHRISTIAN AND I
SPEAK TO WORK. TODAY THE FIRST
DAY HANDING HAND IS A- EMPLOYER
NETWORK AND- THE SECOND IS. THE
EASE SELECT YOUR ELECT. BY I
HAVE A SISTER IN INNER HOME IN
LAKE PORT LAKE FOREST PARK OF
LIKE CAN WHICH IS ONE OF THE
MOST- ACCOUNTING IS IN.
CALIFORNIA YEAH YOU'RE STAYING
HOME ACCORDING TO MY SAID. HAS
NO CO THE CHANGES THAT
PRESIDENT BUT ALSO HOSPICE IS
NOT ALLOWED TO GO IN THERE AND-
THAT INFORMATION THAT I GOT AS
OF YESTERDAY. FROM HER FATHER I
DON'T KNOW IF- DASH ACCURATE
I'M GOING TO DOUBLE CHECK IT.
BUT IT'S JUST POINTS UP SEVERAL
THINGS THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN
SPOKEN OF ONE IS A UNIVERSAL
LONG TERM SERVICE. AT THE TIME
WHEN A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE OUT OF
WORK AND WE HAVEN'T YOU BEEN
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM THAT ONLY YOU
HEALTH CARE IF YOUR WORK. MAKES
THAT POSSIBLE. YOU DIDN'T FOR
PEOPLE WE HAVE BABY BOOMERS
THAT ARE AGING INTO THIS
POPULATION THE ONE TWO AND I
HEARD VERY LITTLE LOVE WHEN
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES MY
SISTER IS MY AGE ROUGHLY AND I
AM HUNGRY EIGHT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TEST AND WE'RE
GETTING EACH PUBLIC COMMENT-
ONE MINUTE- BUT YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY CERTAINLY
NOTE THAT. MODERATOR WILL YOU
PLEASE ASK IF THERE ARE ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES LEFT IN
THE QUEUE. FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
THANK YOU TO WRITE THIRTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS JACKIE AND I'M THE DEPUTY
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA I'D LIKE TO DIRECT
YOU TO OUR READING COMMENTS
SUBMITTED LAST WEEK BUT JUST A
FEW POINTS. AS WE JUST HEARD
CALIFORNIA CANNOT AFFORD TO
WAIT BEFORE IMPLEMENTING SOME
OF THE NECESSARY CHANGES AND
HEALTHCARE NURSING FACILITIES
ARE RUN AND WE SUPPORT CANNERS
TEN POINT PLAN. IF WE ARE TO
ADDRESS BACKING STORAGES THAT
CONTRIBUTE TO THE INDUSTRY'S
ALMOST 60% STAFF TURNOVER RATE
WE MUST ADDRESS PAY FOR THE
FACT THAT THE FACILITIES. THE
NHL TO BE PAID AT OR JUST ABOVE
MINIMUM WAGE WE SHOULD BE
REQUIRING THE ANYTHING FUNDING
TO NURSING HOMES REQUIRE THAT A
BOOK ABOUT MEN GO TOWARD PAYING
THEIR STAFF BETTER. DATA
COLLECTED ALL BECOME A LOT
BETTER. IN THE LAST FEW WEEKS.
IN ORDER TO EVALUATE THAT BACK.
OF COLD AT NIGHT. OKAY THE- AND
I'M CAL MEDICAID WITH THE BE.
ANOTHER MEDIA CHANGE THAT WAS
ALREADY THE- THAT WE THE POOR
IN THE DRY. BY THAT READ THAT
ARE. AS WE BEGIN WE OPEN. AND
LASTLY THE LEAD. SHOULD READ
THE ANY GRANT THAT WOULD MEAN
FROM MY- FOR THE INTO. IN A
TIMELY TRANSPARENT IN ACCOUNT.
IS PARAMOUNT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. THANK YOU
I TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS CAROL
CROOK LIVE IN OAKLAND I'M
ASKING YOU TO TAKE THE
FOLLOWING STEPS WE CALL
ACCOUNTABILITY NOT IMMUNITY.
FOR NURSING FACILITY. NO
PROVIDER SHOULD BE GRANTED
IMMUNITY YOUR SHOULDER WE
CANNOT BE ALREADY FOR THE
DEATHS THAT HAPPEN THERE WATCH
IT BECAUSE OF THE NIGHT HE- ANY
ADDITIONAL FIND PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SHE HUNG. OUT WITH
OVERSIGHT COMPLIANCE WITH IN
TEXAS THESE CONTAIN A PROTOCOL.
AND COMPLIANCE WITH STATE
MANDATED STAFFING RATIOS. NO
MORE STAFFING WAIVERS. THANK
YOU THE POLICE SHOULD. I'M NOT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE
PROVIDING- ONE MINUTE FOR EACH
COMMENT- WILL GO ON WITH THE
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. THANK YOU
I AM FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THERE MY NAME IS NANCY KLINE
MY SON HAS BEEN A NURSING
FACILITIES FOR FOUR AND A HALF
YEARS. AND I'M WELL AWARE THAT
AND THEY CAN SOMETIMES BE
INSENSITIVE OR IN DIFFERENT OR
EVEN ABUSIVE TO THESE PATIENTS
I LIVE ALONE AND I HAVE LEFT
BALLROOM NO NEED TO. CALL THE
NINETEEN AT AND THEN THEN STAFF
MEMBERS AND I THINK BECAUSE OF
PATIENTS CAN BE DEPRESSED AND
AT. AND THEN I WAS ONE. HOW
SOON IT CAN BE ALLOWED TO. FOR
FAMILY MEMBERS PHYSICAL THAT
VISITATION TO OVERSEE HIS CARE
AND TO BE SURE THAT HIS CARE
NEEDS ARE BEING. BEING MAD THAT
CMS TWENTY DASH THIRTY MEMO
THAT YOU MENTIONED I DID READ
THAT THAT WAS ONMAY EIGHTEENTH
AT THEIR IF ANYTHING PROCEEDING
THAT AND- AND IF OF NURSING
HOME SAID THAT THEY HAVE BEEN.
I HAVE NOT HAD TO COPE WITH IT
A MONTH HOW SOON CAN VISITATION
BE EXPECTED. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENT
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. THANK YOU
I THIRTY PLEASE AHEAD. WHY IS
THAT. YES PLEASE PROCEED A LOT.
YEAH MY NAME IS ST PALM I'M A
REACH A GERIATRICIAN AND MY
MOTHER'S IN A NURSING HOME THIS
HAS BEEN. THREE MONTHS ABSOLUTE
SHATTERING AND- I DO- THINK
THAT THEY CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES
FOR NURSING HOME REFORM TEN
POINT PLAN IT'S- IMPORTANT.
THERE SHOULD BE NO STAFF WAVE.
THERE SHOULD BE. THE LADY GET
AT THIS I'M LOCKED OUT SEEING
MY MOM AND MY ONLY RECOURSE IS
TO CALL NINE ONE ONE I TO GET
HER TO AN EMERGENCY ROOM I TO
BRING OUR HOME WHICH I CAN'T DO
BECAUSE I'M HIGH RISK MY SHOP.
ORDER TO. AND CGPA HAS NOT BEEN
ABLE TO ENFORCE. NOT AT ALL AND
THAT NEEDS TO BE LOOKED AT IF
WE HAVE REGULATIONS RIGHT THANK
YOU MA'AM. NOTHING THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENT WIRE YOU WILL
HAVE TO MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
COMMON EACH OF PUBLIC
COMMENTERS GIVEN ONE MINUTE SO
WE THANK YOU FOR THAT
TESTIMONY- MODERATOR JUST AS A
TIME CHECK WE PLEASE ASK IF
THERE ARE ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
AND HOW MANY WE HAVE LEFT IN
THE QUEUE. NINE IN Q.
CURRENTLY. OKAY THANK YOU. NEXT
COMMENT PLEASE. LINE FIFTEEN
PLEASE GLAD. YEAH YOU CAN OPEN
AND THEY HAVE THEIR TWENTY
DOUBLE COULD NOT BE BECAUSE OF
THE WORKERS IN TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
FOR HAVING THE HEARING LIKE TO
NOTE ON A BIG PEOPLE THE
CONVERSATION- I'M NOTHING
SPECIAL ON THE PANEL WHICH IS A
GOOD POINT ON THE WORKERS ARE.
WE SEE HERE YOU SO SORRY TO BUT
YOU'RE LITTLE BIT MUFFLED IF
YOU CAN JUST- SPEAK A LITTLE
BIT. SLOWER AND A LITTLE BIT
MORE CLEARLY. SURE CAN'T OUT BE
RIGHT WITH THE ARE YOU. ON
BEHALF OF OUR- THOUSAND A
NURSING. WORKERS INTO YOUR-
SYSTEM. WE DEFINITELY THINK A
BIG. THE CONVERSATION WITH
MISTY TODAY WHICH IS THE
WORKERS FOUR EIGHT. THEY WERE
ABSENT FROM THE PANEL. I'M
DOCTOR ARE EXPOSED TO COME IN
AT A DAILY BASIS. AND ALSO KEPT
A POSITIVE ON ALARMING RATE TO
DATE THERE HAVE BEEN OVER SIXTY
WORKERS THAT HAVE DIED. I'M
WORKERS GO INTO NEEDS TO GO
BACK HOME INTO THE COMMUNITY.
AND THEY HAVE BEEN. IN THIS
DISEASE. FORTUNATE THE FACILITY
ARE A TO DO GET OUT OF THE-
REQUIRED. ESPECIALLY A TIME
WITH NEEDED TO. WHERE THEY NEED
IT THE MOST I'M MORE CONCERNED
THAT THERE NEED TO BE ADDED. PP
PROVIDE NOW I ON HAND THE
FUTURE. THANK YOU TO BE WHY.
AND CONTAIN TESTING. THANK YOU
FOR THAT TO MAKE SURE THE WHEN
WE ON TO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE SIR. WILL NOTE THAT THINK
YOU FOR THAT NEXT COMMENT
PLEASE. THANK YOU I FIFTY FOUR
PLEASE AHEAD. HI YES THIS
INDOLENT HOW MY FROM ORANGE
COUNTY THE ONE IN ONE TO TALK
TO YOU ABOUT IS THE NEED TO
HAVE ADDITIONAL PP AND THE
FACILITIES MY DAUGHTERS AND ONE
WHERE THIRTY ONE OF THE
PATIENTS TESTED POSITIVE AND
THEY DID THE STAFF. WE REALLY
HAVE TO HAVE MORE PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT AND
ADDITIONALLY CAN WE GET THE
SPOUSES OR PARTNERS OF THE
PERSON YOU TEST POSITIVE THEY
BRING IT HOME TO THEIR FAMILY
THEY ALSO NEED TO BE OFFENCE
WORKERS. MAKING CARE OF THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THOSE COMMENTS NEXT COMMENT IS.
THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS JUDY BRIGHTLY I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK TONY
CICCONE CANNER ALL OF THEIR
WORK. FOURTEEN RIGHT TO
PATIENTS AND PRESIDENT OF OUR
CFCS AN ALE AND YES AND I WOULD
ENCOURAGE ANYONE WHO HAS A
FAMILY MEMBER OR A LOVED ONE IN
OUR CNC OR IF. EARLY RIGHT
TARGETS FAR THE NATION AND
OVERSIGHT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEIR FAMILY MEMBER IS NOT
ISOLATED OR NEGLECTED DURING
THEIR STAY THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. THANK YOU
BYE FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO OUT.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS RICKY
GOLD CORN I'M REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIANS FOR DISABILITY
RIGHTS AND NO BARRIERS DISABLED
ACCESS CONSULTING AN ADVOCATE
FUTURE BUT THAT. MISTER TIGAR
CAL MANY OF HIS COMMENTS WERE
WERE SO ON POINT AND YET WE'RE
SKIPPING OVER ON A LOT OF THE
TEN POINT PLAN IS ON THAT WOULD.
SUBMITTED BY CANNER AND ALL
THAT MUCH PREVAIL. WE ARE
TWENTY FIVE YEARS ALMOST DEAD
WE DECIDE WHERE WE LIVE MY HOME
NOT SOMEONE ELSE'S HOME IF
THAT'S MY CHOICE AND THE VOICES.
AND IT IS UNFORTUNATE THAT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE FAMILIES OF
THE RESIDENTS ARE NOT BEING
LISTENED TO AND DID OPPORTUNITY
RIGHT HERE RIGHT NOW WITH THE
VIRUS THAT IS NOT GOING AWAY
ANYTIME SOON. IT USUALLY TAKES
ABOUT TWO YEARS ON AVERAGE
POLIO TO TWENTY TWO TO BE CALM
NO LONGER AND A CUTE. YOU ASIAN
WE HAVE GOT TO ADDRESS THIS NOW
WILL TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY
THINK JAM AND MAKE SURE THAT WE
LISTENING. AND UP THERE ARE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO BLACKS ECON
ALREADY ARE AND WHAT THE
RESULTS ARE YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. THANK
YOU I'M THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S
LISA COLEMAN AND THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR CAL COLOR THE
CALIFORNIA LONG TERM CARE ABOUT
THE SITUATION I THINK SENATOR
HOLDING THIS HEARING AND I WANT
TO REMIND THE SENATORS THAT
CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE AN
IMPORTANT RESOURCE FOR SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY TENSIONS
DRIVING FACILITY ACT I'VE READ
THAT. AND THAT'S A LONG TERM
CARE OMBUDSMAN BUT AT THE
MOMENT THEY'RE NOT IN THE
FACILITIES AND WE NEED TO. WE
NEED TO WORK WITH C. AND LAST
AND WITH THE LOCAL DEPARTMENT
TO FIND. A WAY. YOU GET THE- TO
GET BACK HOME TO THE BUILDINGS.
IT WAS MENTIONED THERE BEEN A
SIGNET. DECLINE IN FACILITIES
RICK A BEING. ARE LOCAL. TO
REPORTING A FROM FORTY TO EAT
AFTER. PERCENT DECLINE. IN THE
PHILLIES REPORT COMPLY WITH GUY
TO GET THE ON IN THEIR- I WANT
TO GO BACK TO GENDER POINT
ABOUT THE LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND SOME OF THE CONFUSION IN
THE VERY BEGINNING AND THERE
CERTAINLY WERE EXCEPTIONS AND
THAT THE PANELISTS. DISHES
PROBABLY NOT SPECIFICALLY
DIRECTED TO DAB BUT MANY OF OUR
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH. WHAT THEY
DID A WONDERFUL JOB AND THEY
WERE NOT EXPERTS IN LICENSE
LONG TERM CARE AND I WOULD
ENCOURAGE LEGISLATION MOVING
FORWARD THAT WOULD INCLUDE A
REGIONAL EXPERT LIKE A LONG
TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN THANK YOU
HELP WITH THE PLANNING. FOR
REGIONAL PROGRAMMING THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE APPRECIATE THAT
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. THANK YOU
LINE TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME'S BUT
THERE'S A COUPLE OF THE SAME
JUST GO GRAY PANTHERS NATIONAL
COUNCIL GREAT PANTHER NETWORKS
WE ARE OUTRAGED IN DEMAND
ENFORCEABLE STANDARDS THAT ARE
ACTUALLY ENFORCED FOR TESTING
EQUIPMENT TRANSPARENCY STAFFING
RATIOS RESIDENTS RIGHTS WORKER
RIGHTS AND ACCOUNTABILITY
INCLUDING MAKING SURE THERE'S
NO IMMUNITY FROM LONG TERM CARE
FACILITIES OR NURSING HOMES
FROM ILLNESS OR DEATH. HAVE
HAPPENING UNDER THEIR WATCH.
THANK ARE WANTED INVESTIGATION
OF THE NURSING HOME INDUSTRY.
THEIR FINANCES AND
MANIPULATIONS HIDE THEIR WE
WANT TO BOOKS OPENED AND I WANT
YOU TO AS OTHERS HAVE SAID
LISTEN TO THE RESIDENTS LISTEN
TO THE WORKERS ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY CHECK AND TELL. LISTEN
TO THE UNIONS. DON'T BE
DISSUADED FROM INVESTIGATING BY
THE NURSING HOME INDUSTRY AND
THEIR INTEREST IN MAKING MONEY
OUT OF THIS DEADLY SITUATION
DOES WERE NURSING HOMES FINALLY
NEED TO BE LOOKED AT VERY
CAREFULLY FOR THINGS THAT A MAN
GOING ON LONG FOR SO MANY YEARS
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND MODERATOR JUST ANOTHER TIME
FACT. DO YOU KNOW HOW MANY MORE
UP PUBLIC COMMENTERS WE HAVE IN
THE QUEUE. I CURRENTLY HAVE
THREE LEFT IN Q. THANK YOU.
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. LINE
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS REGINA EVEN
THOUGH IT'S HARD TO LIKE THE
JOURNEY I LIVE IN THE
CONTINUING CARE COMMUNITY AND
FAMILY TO GO WE'VE BEEN VRY
FORTUNATE TO HAVE OUR
MANAGEMENT TO. AND PART BECAUSE
WE ADVOCATE FOR ITSELF I
LOOKING TO GET THE DATA
ASSEMBLY. HEARING AND I WANNA
BRING OUT. FOR PAYING. FROM A
CONSUMER OR RESIDENT POINT OF
VIEW THAT I THINK ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT. BUT FIRST THIS
COMMUNICATION FOR A- FAMILY.
DISCLOSURE COPE WITH CASES
TRANSPARENT THE BY PROVIDING
INFORMATION ABOUT STAFFING
LEVEL COMPACTION CONTROL
PROTOCOL ALL OF THOSE THINGS.
PEOPLE ARE ANXIOUS FOR THAT
INFORMATION. A LOT OF IT'S NOT
READILY AVAILABLE CHICAGO.
STRONG A THE RETURN OF HONG
FUNDS FIRST. BACK INTO FELONIES
IT SHOULD BE UP TO THEM AS
WHETHER THEY WANT TO GO INTO
MAYBE STEPS CAN WEAR GO. AND GO
AROUND. AND ISSUE ISSUE. BUT
IT'S IMPORTANT I THINK GROUPS.
AND TO BE TO BE ABLE TO ABOUT
TO THIRD OF THE- FROM THE
FEDERAL AND LOCAL LEVEL TOOLS.
INCLUDE UNDERSTAND FOR THE
AVERAGE. ROCKETS LET YOU FINISH
UP HERE BUT WE'RE WE'RE INTO
INDEED NOW. DID YOU WANT TO GO
HEAD FINISH COMMON. ALRIGHT I
THINK. WE'LL MOVE MOVE ON TO
THE NECK COMMENT. THANK I'VE
FIVE PLEASE AHEAD. THANK YOU
NAME IS MARTY A MOTO FAMILY
MEMBER ADVOCATE FOR CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY SENIOR COMMUNITY
ACTION NETWORK YOU CAN THANK
YOU FOR THIS HEARING- JUST WANT
TO SAY THAT MY WHEN MY OLDER
SISTER ELENA WHO HAVE
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES WAS
IN A NURSING FACILITY FOR PART
OF OUR LIVES- VISITATION WITH
THE CRITICAL PART. OF YOUR CARE
AND SUPPORT SO URGE THE STATE
SENATE TO REALLY- SUPPORT ALL
OF US IN. OR VISITATION THAT IS
A PART OF OVERSIGHT AND LASTLY
SUPPORT FOR MS HE HE BASS
REGIONAL CENTER FUNDING IN THE-
PLAN OF THE LEGISLATURE'S- TO
REJECTED TRIGGER CUTS THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR THIS HEARING. THANK
YOU AS WELL. I THINK WE'RE
COMING UP TO OUR LAST- PUBLIC
COMMENT NEXT COME PLEASE. THANK
YOU I'M FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD
IDEA AND- REGISTERED NURSE FOR
FORTY NINE YEAR MY THIRD
APPLICATION DURING YOUR AND
POLITICAL NURSING IN NURSING
ADMINISTRATION. I WANT TO THANK
THANK YOU FOR HAVING THE
HEARING THANK YOU FOR THE
VOICES I WANT TO GIVE YOU A
PERSPECTIVE FROM THE INSIDE. OF
OUR LONG TERM ACUTE SETTING
RATHER THAN NINE HEARING FROM
THE OUTSIDE EVERYBODY WHO WORKS
IN LONG TERM CARE WORKS HARD.
WE LOVE OUR RESIDENTS YEAH
NOBODY IS TAKING INTO ACCOUNT
THAT WE REALIZED HOW HARD IT IS
WHEN FAMILIES CAN'T VISIT BUT
WE HAVE TO FOLLOW THE
GUIDELINES. THE OTHER THING
ABOUT WAIVER RECAPPING AS THE
DIRECTOR OF NURSING IN THE PAST
YOU CANNOT CREATE I CAN'T
LEGISLATE. MORALITY CAN'T
LEGISLATE A CAREER WE CAN'T
THEY HAVE TO HAVE LABOR IF WE
DON'T HAVE THE AND THEY WE
DON'T HAVE THAT THEY CAN COME
IN THE STAFF AT THE BOAT THEY
HAVE TO BE QUARANTINED FOR
FOURTEEN DAYS. THAT LEADS THE
GAS. THERE'S A LOT OF FEAR OUT
THERE STILL AMONG OUR-
EMPLOYEES AND ALL AMONG THE
FAMILY SO PLEASE DON'T HEAR THE
BABY OUT WITH THE BAND BUILDING
YOU ARE PERFECT AND LOVE IT AND
WE- THERE. THANK YOU THANK AS
WELL AND AN ARRAY CAN YOU
PLEASE VERIFY THAT THERE ARE NO
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
Q. I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
SINK YOU AT THIS TIME. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WELL I
WANT TO THANK ALL OF OUR
PANELISTS- ALL FIVE OF THEM
MEMBERS- FOR ASKING THEIR
QUESTIONS AS WELL AS MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WHO ASKED- PROVIDED
PUBLIC TAMALE BUT ALSO PERSONAL
STORIES ABOUT THIS. TO YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS- SO IF
THERE'S ADDITIONAL- QUESTIONS
YOU CAN CERTAINLY VISIT OUR-
SENATE COMMITTEE ON PANDEMIC.
THE RESPONSE A WEBSITE. I THINK
YOU WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION THIS WILL
CONCLUDE OUR- MEAT WE ARE
ADJOURNED.